mes chers collègues à la demande de
plusieurs d'entre vous et je salue à
vigilait nous sommes aujourd'hui une
séquence d'audition qui vont être
consacrées à l'eau cette ressourcie
précieuse sur laquelle il n'y a pas de
vie
pendant longtemps notre pays il s'est
bercé de l'illusion que la ressource en
eau était illimité grâce à son climat
tempéré à sa pluviométrie abondante et
régulière ainsi qu'à des agrifères à aux
effets
contracycle qui joue le rôle de masse
d'eau de réserve pour répondre aux
besoins de l'été qui se recharge en
hiver le cycle idéal n'est plus qu'un
souvenir la donne hydrique a changé car
l'or bleu est devenu rare et ce n'est
pas un scoop pour personne de
concitoyens font la mère expérience
d'épisodes de sécheresse épisode chaque
année de plus en plus sévère plus en
plus fréquent et plus en plus long plus
d'une centaine de communes ont été dans
l'incapacité de fournir de l'eau potable
à leurs habitants au plus fort de la
canicule l'été dernier c'est une
situation inédite qui a marqué les
esprits avec des approvisionnements par
camion qui sont leur révélateur de la
fragilité de nos réseaux et de notre
dépendance souvent oubliée aux
performances des services d'adduction
d'eau
dans ce contexte il m'a paru fondamental
que la Commission s'intéresse à nouveau
à ce sujet alors notamment des
évolutions du contexte climatique et
hydrologique la bonne gestion de l'eau
est un pays quiz essentiel à un contexte
social apaisé la rareté de l'eau peut
conduire à des conflits d'usage conflit
délicat à résoudre mais plus grave
encore à des conflits d'usagers ce qu'il
faut à tout prix éviter les défis et ils
sont importants sont devant nous et il
est nécessaire de s'y préparer nous ne
partons naturellement pas d'une feuille
blanche mais il faut que cette feuille
dont les premières lignes ont déjà été
tracées deviennent une véritable feuille
de route pour rassurer la résilience
hydrique de la France notre première
table ronde sur ce thème consacré à la
gestion de la compétence des deux par
les collectivités territoriales dans un
contexte de changement climatique cela
n'étonnera personne le Sénat étant
l'assemblée des territoires
pour explorer ce vaste sujet et les
nombreuses questions qu'il soulèvent
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
Monsieur Thierry Burlot président du
Cercle français de l'eau une association
créée en 1990 par notre ancien collègue
jakoudun sénateur de la Vendée monsieur
Burlot et par ailleurs président du
comité de bassin Loire-Bretagne Monsieur
Bruno Forel président et Frédéric
molossi co-président de l'Association
nationale des élus de bassin
mais en visio Baptiste Julien
responsable du pôle haut de
l'association amorce un réseau
d'informations de partage d'expérience
et d'accompagnement des collectivités en
matière de transition énergétique et de
gestion durable je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté d'être en visio quel repose sur
une organisation en régie ou une
délégation de service public l'exercice
de la compétence haut et assainissement
et confronté à des défis nouveaux
raréfaction de la ressource rénovation
des réseaux vieillissants caractérisé
par de forte taux de fuite ou
tarification aux usagers un important
levier d'investissement que peu d'élus
utilisent il y a une forme
d'anachronisme à rester sur l'idée que
la modicité du prix de l'eau est un
indicateur de bonne gestion de la
compétence
dans un avenir proche il faudra
nécessairement débattre de la facture
d'eau le prix étant un puissant vecteur
de sobriété pour mettre fin ou
gaspillage à condition que des actions
de sensibilisation du grand public
soient menée en parallèle la voie est
cependant étroite la fourniture d'une
autre qualité à un coût maîtrisé est un
enjeu de premier plan pour les services
d'eau et les usagers même si l'idée
d'une tarification de l'eau à l'aune des
contraintes pesant sur la ressource fait
son chemin j'aimerais vous entendre sur
ce sujet cette question me paraît
essentielle pour le petit cycle de l'eau
alors que de nombreux élus locaux
déplorent le désengagement relatif des
agences de l'eau pour la rénovation des
canalisations la rénovation des ouvrages
de traitement à ce propos j'ai récemment
publié une tribune tribune largement
cosignée par les parlementaires appelant
un plan d'urgence nationale haut qui
déclinerait entre autres mesurent un
ambitieux programme de rénovation des
réseaux
notre pays est un bon élève historique
en matière de gestion et de traitement
de la ressource hydrique à tel point
qu'on parle souvent de l'école française
de l'eau mais il ne faut pas baisser la
gare ni abandonner le soutien financier
au collectivités gestionnaires je
rappelle que la Commission européenne
cours de justice de l'Union européenne
d'un recours en manquement le 9 juin
2021 car les conditions de traitement
des eaux urbaines résidèrent de 169
heures agglomération d'assainissement et
2000 habitants de 2000 habitants et plus
non conforme à la directive européenne à
ce jour 92 présente à nouveau des
performances conformes aux exigences de
la directive mais 77 sont toujours en
cours de mise en conformité il y a là un
point d'attention sur lequel la
Commission souhaiterait recueillir votre
avis
j'aimerais également évoquer les
réformes à mener pour lever le tabou de
la réutilisation des eaux usées on
arrose aujourd'hui les pelouses avec de
l'eau potable les voitures sont lavées
avec la même eau que celles qui sert à
la cuisson de nos aliments comment
mettre fin à cette aberration quelles
sont les freins à desserrer pour avancer
sur ce sujet sans un moindre rire la
sécurité sanitaire des populations ce ne
sont là que des premières pistes pour
engager le dialogue avec la Commission
et je ne doute pas et j'en suis certain
parce que j'ai déjà beaucoup de
collègues inscrits pour des questions je
ne doute pas que mes collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs auront bien
d'autres questions à vous poser je vous
donne la parole je ne sais pas dans quel
ordre allez-y 1 2 3 voilà on va le faire
dans ce sens là merci
merci monsieur le Président donc bonjour
à toutes et à tous je vais essayer en
quelques mots
de vous dire un peu
[Musique]
mon sentiment sur ce qu'on vient de
vivre
et finalement essayer d'esquisser des
des pistes de progrès sur ce dossier
essentiel qui est l'eau
d'abord l'été 2022 nous a permis de
comprendre tout ce que l'eau n'était pas
inépuisable
et que c'est un bien commun et que c'est
un bien essentiel au développement
économique à l'attractivité de nos
territoires
sans eau pas de santé publique sans eau
pas d'énergie sans eau pas d'urbanisme
sans eau pas d'industrie bref l'eau cet
été on s'est rendu compte et vous vous
êtes rendu compte aussi bien sûr que
finalement
son manque
profondément marqué
nos territoires et particulièrement nos
territoires ruraux
je prends l'exemple de la pomme de terre
et c'est pas Gérard Laennec qui va me
contredire
dans le pays de Plug sur lié pays de la
pomme de terre c'est moins 50 % de
production cette année c'est moins 50%
de haricots verts en France à cause du
manque d'eau donc aujourd'hui l'eau est
précieuse et
rare et on s'est rendu compte que
finalement il fallait que l'on regarde
ça avec attention et on se réveille un
peu douloureusement après comme vous
l'avez fort bien dit monsieur le
président
un pays qui était plutôt pas mal
organisé autour de la loi de 64 sur
l'eau qui est une loi fondatrice qui a
fait les choses assez bien en créant ce
qu'on appelle les périmètres
hydrographiques les agences de l'eau
donc les agences financières de l'eau
les périmètres hydrographiques
c'est-à-dire la relation entre la montée
Laval et surtout la certaine forme de
démocratie participative autour de la
question de l'eau on a eu la loi de 92
ensuite qui a créé les sages jusqu'à
décentraliser la loi de 64 et ça c'est
plutôt bien fait
tellement bien fait d'ailleurs que notre
pays est une référence à l'international
en termes de gestion
et on avait presque oublié cela et je me
souviens avoir participé à un forum
mondial de l'eau et il fallait à
l'étranger pour s'entendre dire que le
modèle français est un bon modèle
alors vous vous dites mais comment on a
pu faire et en arriver là avec un bon
modèle alors pour moi il y a il y a
trois sujets trois sujets majeurs
d'abord le premier c'est de te dire que
le petit cycle de l'eau ça a bien
fonctionné monsieur le Président on
l'avait dit aujourd'hui tout le monde a
l'eau au robinet
et ça se passe plutôt bien et ça se
passe plutôt bien alors évidemment il y
a toujours quelques exceptions Nadège
mais ça marche plutôt bien et et on a
même mis en place l'assainissement donc
voilà alors on peut toujours faire mieux
mais mais j'ai envie de dire que le
petit cycle de l'eau il a assez bien
fonctionné
et vous l'avez dit monsieur le président
il y a des inégalités tarifaires parce
que dans les territoires ruraux on paye
généralement plus cher que dans les
territoires urbains mais ça s'explique
aussi par la configuration des réseaux
et pas le nombre d'abonnés au kilomètre
de tuyaux
on sait tous ça et parfois on nous fait
un débat sur le mode de gestion mais
franchement
s'il y a eu des abuses le mode de
gestion il y a quelques années
aujourd'hui les choses sont sous
maîtrises publiques on va dire
donc ça aux collectivités aussi donc le
sujet il est pas trop là le sujet il est
aujourd'hui sur le grand cycle de l'eau
ce qu'on appelle le Grand Cycle même si
j'aime pas faire la différence entre un
petit et grand parce que c'est la même
eau mais il est sous le grand cycle
alors juste un petit un petit point de
puisque nous vous avez posé des
questions monsieur le Président sur le
petit site qui aura des choses à
améliorer
interconnexion des réseaux sécurisation
rendement des réseaux
mais ça on sait faire j'ai envie de dire
on sait faire après il faut être
solidaire et vous avez compris Madame et
Monsieur sénateurs que on est solidaire
surtout qu'on quand on a quelque chose à
gagner quoi parce que il y a ce qui paye
pas qui veulent toujours payer moins
mais on peut faire et ça c'est facile
enfin techniquement non moi je prends
l'exemple de la Bretagne j'en parlais
tout à l'heure avec Madame c'est je
prends les départements les plus
sécurisés c'est les plus interconnectés
et ça c'est une leçon de cet été aussi
là on a coupé l'eau c'est là où il y
avait pas de et il y a territoire qui
sont plus fragiles que l'autre mais
encore une fois tu sais que je suis pas
inquiet
il faudra qu'on travaille sur la
réutilisation tout ça mais on en parlera
dans un deuxième temps si vous alors sur
le Grand Cycle là c'est compliqué
pourquoi c'est compliqué
d'abord la première raison c'est que le
périmètre hydrographique n'est pas de
périmètre politique de décision
le périmètre hydrographique le périmètre
de la rivière n'est pas le périmètre
politique de l'organisation des
territoires et là il y a un vrai sujet
il y a un vrai sujet parce que d'abord
qui décide
et est-ce qu'il y a cohérence alors pour
mon propos
ou pour illustrer mon propos je vais
prendre l'exemple des stages
on vient de voter en Loire-Bretagne le
schéma d'aménagement de gestion des eaux
donc du Mont Gerbier des gens jusqu'à la
pointe du Conquet
comme si on pouvait d'ailleurs faire un
document de planification aussi vaste un
périmètre aussi différent enfin on a
voté un stage puisque c'est sont les
agences enfin les comités de bassin qui
votent des stages
avec ce plan souviens un certain nombre
de difficultés de tension sur le sujet
mais on l'a voté
j'ai regardé avec attention la vie de
l'autorité environnementale
et l'autoritaire nous a dit c'est très
joli votre stage mais vous parlez pas au
stade des régions
comme si on pouvait écrire une politique
de l'os sans écrire une politique
économique et d'aménagement du
territoire
c'est juste
alors je suis allé voir le stade
d'intérêt région et je suis allé voir la
ville d'autorité environnementale sur
l'estralette des régions
et j'ai lu très bien mais vous parlez
pause
donc personne ne se parle
et là c'est une des premières
incohérences politiques de la politique
de l'eau c'est que la politique de l'eau
elle s'est enfermée et je ne j'accuse
personne je constate elle s'est enfermée
dans la technique
en oubliant que la politique de l'eau
c'est vraiment de la avant toute la
politique d'aménagement du territoire et
de développement économique
et c'est bien le développement
économique et l'aménagement du
territoire qui fait la qualité de l'eau
nappes phréatique et nos rivières et
c'est pas autre chose
donc si c'est politique là ne se croise
pas on passe à côté de quelque chose
donc la première
incohérence c'est que ce périmètre
hydrographique qui existe puisque non
seulement on a fait des âges mais
maintenant on fait des sages et je
laisserai mes collègues en parler ils en
parlant beaucoup mieux que moi donc je
sache dans les bassins
bon je vais essayer de faire quoi ça
mais les sages c'est pareil ne parle pas
forcément aux intercommunalités par
exemple
donc les intercommunalités ils écrivent
des scottes des pluies etc sans se
soucier de la question de l'eau de son
prélèvement et surtout sa capacité pure
à toi
donc si la politique de l'eau n'arrive
pas à parler aux politiques agricoles
d'aménagement du territoire et
développement économique on passe à côté
tout seul le deuxième sujet
et celui-là je le porter auprès d'eux
parce qu'il est il est important c'est
que le financement du petit cycle qui
fonctionne assez bien
plus je consomme plus je paye
ça a du sens par contre le grand cycle
de l'Eau Loire Bretagne c'est 30% du
territoire national
le fruit des redevances de l'Agence de
l'eau au niveau national c'est 2
milliards d'euros
le arbre Bretagne 30% des territoires
nationales c'est 380 millions d'euros
cette Normandie 20% du territoire
national 900 millions d'euros
c'est à dire que les territoires ruraux
qui sont les plus vastes
n'ont pas de redevance et quand on
travaille sur le grand cycle de l'eau
vous imaginez bien que c'est pas la même
musique
et donc aujourd'hui
on n'a pas les moyens si je puis dire
d'agir sur le grand cycle de l'eau
compte tenu de la faiblesse des moyens
financiers
et
moi je suis convaincu qu'après l'été
qu'on vient de vivre
plus que jamais tout le monde a compris
qu'il fallait qu'on fasse des efforts
sur le Grand Cycle qu'on soit plus sobre
pour faire protéger la ressource etc et
pour ce faire il faut pas que ça soit
uniquement que des contraintes
contrainte pour l'agriculteur contrainte
pour le propriétaire contrainte pour la
commune
et que si on veut avoir une politique
ambitieuse sur le grand cycle de l'eau
il faut mettre ce patrimoine commun au
service du bien commun et lui donner les
moyens
et un peu de fierté pour agir
et l'environnement c'est pas que de la
récession c'est pas que de la
décroissance ça doit être aussi une
ambition politique
et une ambition politique à laquelle on
donne des moyens pour aider nos
agriculteurs qui feront les efforts pour
aider les communes qui feront des
efforts
et ainsi de suite vous savez moi quand
vous regardez un peu la fiscalité locale
aujourd'hui plus vous urbanisez plus
vous imperméabilisez plus vous vous
développez plus vous avez d'impact sur
la ressource en eau plus vous êtes aidé
et à l'inverse plus vous êtes dans une
démarche de protection de préservation
du bien commun de classement des zones
de classement du bocage vous n'avez que
la contrainte encore une fois pour le
propriétaire pour l'exploitant et pour
la commune et sans aucune rétrocession
pour le bien public si on veut changer
le modèle il faut donner plus de fierté
plus de reconnaissance à ceux qui font
le bien commun
merci merci je vous donne la parole
combien merci merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs merci de nous accueillir on va
essayer de tenir les 5 minutes qui nous
sont dévolus pour permettre un échange
avec chacune et chacun d'entre vous
peut-être brièvement vous dire que
l'Association nationale des élus de
bassins comme son nom l'indique regroupe
des élus locaux voilà qui représentent
leur territoire et qui sont investis à
travers différents outils qui existent
sur nos territoires qu'il s'agisse des
clés qu'il s'agisse des établissements
publics territoriaux de bassin des
syndicats de rivière sur la question du
grand cycle de l'eau
brièvement mais sans redire ce qu'elle
dit à l'instant Thierry Burlot mais vous
allez vite comprendre qu'il y a un
certain nombre de points de convergence
entre ces propos et ce que mon collègue
Bruno Forel et moi allons tenir devant
vous d'abord nous nous avons deux deux
principes fondamentaux auxquels nous
sommes fondamentalement attachés le
premier c'est que l'eau est un bien
commun et la période qui a été rappelée
ne serait-ce que de cet été témoignent
effectivement de la nécessité de
rappeler constamment cette cette
première exigence en tout cas ce premier
point de vue le deuxième
le deuxième point de vue nous tenons
profondément à ce qui a été le marqueur
de la politique de l'eau en France et
qui comme ça a été dit était aussi un
marqueur à
l'extérieur qui est la dimension de
l'échelle de bassin versant comme la
bonne échelle pour aborder la question
du cycle du grand cycle de l'eau
je dis ça dans le dans la mesure où ces
dernières années nous avons connu en
matière de gestion du grand cycle de
l'eau
quelques bouleversements liés à quelques
textes de loi
la loi neutre et la loi maptam notamment
qui ont
modifié sensiblement le paysage
notamment à l'échelle des collectivités
qui étaient un peu ferme de Lens de ces
sujets-là je pense là en l'occurrence au
Conseil départementaux avec un fléchage
qui vous l'aurez compris avec notamment
la création de la gemapi a été
dirigée vers le bloc communal à travers
les EPCI à fiscalité propre ou les
métropoles là où elles existent et donc
nous sommes dans une situation où nous
les choses se mettent en place
progressivement ils sont loin d'être
aboutis à l'échelle nationale il y a
encore de grandes disparités en la
matière et le deuxième le troisième
point que je voulais évoquer c'est que
en ce qui nous concerne en tout cas nous
ne sommes pas favorables un grand soir
ou à de nouveaux bouleversement du cadre
juridique dans lequel nous évoluons mais
plutôt sur un certain nombre de
propositions qui visent à clarifier à
renforcer et à pérenniser selon nous un
certain nombre d'outils qui nous
semblent exister mais qui parfois
ont du mal à se déployer ou ne
bénéficient pas à nos yeux d'un poids
notamment
juridique suffisamment et politique
suffisamment affirmée
la première chose que je voudrais
exprimer devant vous c'est pour nous une
nécessité absolue de voir sur l'ensemble
du territoire national ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui
[Musique]
se mettre en place des outils de
planification territoriales
je pense en particulier aux clés mais
aussi aux sages et aux stages mais au
sage en particulier qui sont vous
l'aurez compris des outils existants
mais dont si vous observez la carte de
du territoire national ne sont pas
déployés sur l'ensemble du territoire et
il nous semble que la première question
quand on doit aborder la question du
grand cycle et des enjeux qui sont les
siens tiens d'abord au fait de partager
avec l'ensemble des acteurs de la
question du Grand Cycle que ce soit bien
évidemment les élus locaux le monde
agricole le monde industriel de manière
plus large la question de l'aménagement
du territoire avec toutes les toutes les
réalités qu'il recouvrent c'est donc
d'aller vers l'extension et la
couverture de l'ensemble du territoire
national d'outils planification partagée
il nous semble être d'autant plus utile
qu'ils sont à nos yeux en tout cas le
gage à la fois de l'ouverture de
dialogue avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et en même temps de
l'élaboration d'un document stratégique
partagé et on a bien vu encore récemment
du côté par exemple de la Charente pour
nécessité que le dernier exemple
d'actualité combien les conflits d'usage
aujourd'hui apparaissent sur leur
territoire et combien il est
indispensable de les éviter à tout prix
pour éviter toute montée en puissance de
ces conflits d'usage et selon nous la
meilleure chemin pour les éviter ou en
tout cas les apaiser et de faire en
sorte de partager ensemble une vision
commune et stratégique de moyens et long
terme sur la manière dont nous
souhaitons aborder les questions les
questions relatives à la gestion du
grand cycle de l'eau
le troisième le deuxième élément sur
lequel nous sommes auquel nous sommes
également très attachés c'est la
nécessité de rétablir ou de renforcer
l'ingénierie publique
on appuie à la mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie collective qui aurait été
préalablement vous l'aurez compris
déterminé et là nous pensons en
particulier au à la clarification et au
renforcement des compétences des
établissements publics de bassin qui ont
pour vocation je le rappelle
devrait aller chez le clés ou des
inter-clés et qui nous semble
au lendemain de la mise en oeuvre de la
gemapi et je m'arrêterai sur ce point-là
avant de passer la parole à mon collègue
Bruno Forel qui nous semble des outils
non seulement d'ingénierie mais qui
doivent garantir
précisément la cohérence de
l'intervention et de la maîtrise ouvrage
à l'échelle du bassin versant or
précisément la gemapi
a des aspects extrêmement positifs
notamment le fait qu'elle puisse être
qu'elle ait été fléchée notamment au
bloc communal et dans la mesure où elle
renvoie la question du rapport entre
l'eau et son et le grand cycle et la
question de l'aménagement du territoire
tel que Thierry Burlot l'a évoqué son
propos sur lequel nous nous sommes
d'accord en même temps et c'est l'altool
paradoxe il nous semble qu'il y a un
trou dans la raquette c'est à dire que
dès lors que la gemapie s'installe à
l'échelle et du bloc communal s'il n'y a
pas selon nous des outils de gouvernance
et en particulier de maîtrise d'ouvrage
et d'ingénierie à l'échelle du bassin
versant il y a un risque à terme y
compris face aux difficultés auxquelles
sont confrontées les collectivités
d'une espèce de saucissonnage de de du
bassin du bassin versant et d'un repli
que l'on peut parfois constater déjà des
EPCI sur leur propre territoire sans
tenir compte de l'absolu nécessité
d'être en écho avec l'amant et Laval
soit bien évidemment en écho mais aussi
le monde rural et le monde urbain
puisque vous l'aurez compris selon nous
au total la politique du grand cycle de
l'eau doit être une politique de
solidarité territoires entre eux et de
cohérence et donc nous pensons
absolument nécessaire non seulement de
déployer des établissements publics de
bassins mais dans clarifier et dont
renforcer les compétences ce qui n'est
pas aujourd'hui selon nous en tout cas
suffisamment affirmé et je pense que
Bruno tu peux peut-être enchaîner le
player Forel je vous donne la parole
pardon il faut appuyer ça a été dit la
ressource Renault nous pose aujourd'hui
une vraie question en réalité la
difficulté
se situe entre nos schémas
administratifs au niveau des territoires
la manière qu'on a dont on a organisé
l'Administration du territoire et sa
réalité du fonctionnement en effet
nos territoires sont administrés selon
des limites administratives nombreux et
diverses régions départements
intercommunalités communes qui ne sont
pas raccords avec le périmètre de
fonctionnement de l'eau
il est donc essentiel d'essayer de
trouver une articulation qui permet
face à une ressource non la pénurie nous
est gravissime de trouver un moyen de
reconstruire un lien efficace entre la
répartition territoriale
d'administrative classique et le mode de
gestion et de compréhension du système
de l'eau qui s'établit par bassin
versant
c'est pas une nouveauté absolue puisque
effectivement des établissements publics
de bassins ont été créés qui permettent
de le faire de grands établissements
publics de Bassens sur de grands sur de
grands bassin versants c'est des agences
de l'eau et district et c'est
parfaitement efficace et ça a été
mondialement
apprécié et souvent copié
il faut pour arriver à gérer les choses
proprement descendre plus bas dans la
maille un territoriale et c'est bien la
difficulté de l'eau c'est
l'eau ça se traite au niveau très local
et ça doit aussi avoir une vision
globale donc on est dans cette tension
là comment comment arriver à faire en
sorte que l'eau qui se gère sur un
périmètre hydrographique puisse être
correctement travaillé avec des
périmètres administratifs qui ne
poussent pas ce périmètre de
fonctionnement
c'est ce que je propose de faire
l'établissement public de bassin
en s'appuyant aujourd'hui et un autre
sens c'est un bon système sur la maille
la plus territoriale qui soit c'est à
dire le bloc communal qui se réunit dans
des syndicats qui constituent des
établissements publics de bassin alors
il est vrai qu'il y a un certain nombre
de variantes et on a aujourd'hui des
établissements publics de bassins qui
intègre des départements et des régions
parce que des bassins versants peuvent
être très très grands
on peut travailler à des mailles où on a
un établissement public de bassins
global et plusieurs établissements
publics de bassins qui vont travailler
sur des sous bassins c'est possible de
le penser de cette manière là cependant
il faut donner une puissance de
fonctionnement à cette échelle là et en
termes de compétences il nous semble
qu'il est intéressant que la compétence
première de l'os reste au bloc communal
et qu'on associe l'échelle
départementale et régionales dans une
compétence plus large qui leur
permettrait d'intervenir sur ces
domaines en soutien mais en s'assurant
de travailler avec une cohésion et une
coopération qui descend au plus bas du
territoire c'est-à-dire au plus près du
terrain c'est-à-dire à l'échelle
communale et intercommunale
cette réalité là nous permettrait cette
manière d'aborder les choses nous
permettrait d'assurer cette tension
entre le plus bas niveau du terrain et
le niveau le plus le plus global
je voudrais insister sur un autre point
qui a déjà été évoqué il est vrai et
constatable que sans doute il manque un
lien assez fort entre le stage et les
stradettes
cependant et là je pense que c'est très
très important qu'on y arrive
cependant il existe déjà dans les textes
des liens qui sont très forts entre les
sages les scottes les pluies ou les
pluies ils sont écrits comme tel
c'est-à-dire que
il doit y avoir par définition un
rapport de compatibilité entre chacun de
ces documents
or pour cette constater que ce rapport
de compatibilité qui devrait être à mon
sens une des préoccupations première de
l'action de l'État dans les territoires
de vérifier que les textes tels qui sont
écrits soient bien suivis des faits
semble particulièrement peut
scrupuleux sur le sujet et je pense que
si on
n'insistait largement sur le pouvoir
régalien de l'État en la matière de
faire exécuter les textes et que chacun
des documents d'urbanisme qui régissent
les construction et le développement
urbain on arriverait sans doute à avoir
de bien meilleurs résultats parce que ce
qu'il ne faut pas oublier et c'est
vraiment essentiel et notre collègue
Thierry Burlot a commencé sur ce sujet
là
c'est que le grand aujourd'hui la
pénurie que nous vivons n'est pas due à
une mauvaise gestion du petit cycle de
l'eau effectivement les lois qui ont qui
ont appelé à passer à l'échelle
intercommunale et qui ont favorisé la
connexion des petits systèmes vers des
systèmes de plus d'assiette qui
permettent plus de sécurité
d'approvisionnement plus de qualité
d'ingénierie vont dans le bon sens et ce
travail est en route et c'est une très
bonne chose mais au-delà de ça si nous
avons de la perruine pénurie c'est parce
que notre grand cycle de l'eau est en
train de subir des modifications
importantes et nous pouvons faire un
travail pour améliorer la situation et
faire en sorte que ce gros cycle de
l'eau sans revenir à ce qu'il était
précédemment ne nous ne nous joue pas
des tours aussi aussi compliqué depuis
10 à 15 ans les sols français dans sa
dans leur globalité s'achètent en
permanence
les scientifiques le montrent avec
clarté nous sommes dans un cycle où
l'eau sera une denrée plus rare qu'elle
n'était autrefois l'aménagement du
territoire la gestion de nos paysages la
gestion de nos villes la manière dont on
urbanisme tout ça peut conclure
largement à assurer que nous sommes en
capacité de continuer de répondre à nos
besoins les plus fondamentaux sans doute
faudra-t-il aussi regardez un tout petit
peu la manière dont nous utilisons cette
eau assez clairement peut-être faire des
choix culturels peut-être faire des
soins industriels un tout petit peu
différents pour essayer d'être plus
économe cependant c'est bien le grand
cycle de l'eau qu'il faut arriver à
mieux maîtriser ce rapport entre les
documents d'urbanisme qui déterminent
l'aménagement du territoire économique
et industriel est essentiel et il me
semble qu'à la fois en donnant aux
établissements publics de bassins comme
ça a été dit une existence juridique qui
attire plus l'action politique de
terrain vers ce genre d'établissement en
lui donnant un vrai une vraie capacité
de peser sur les documents d'urbanisme
et en ayant un état qui soit très
scrupuleux sur l'application et le bon
articulation on sera en capable on sera
incapable de répondre aux défis et il me
semble que le défi est perçu par tous
puisque comme vous l'avez très bien vu
après des assises de lourd on a eu un
arrêt de l'eau et que là on nous prépare
de nouveau encore une modification une
annonce forte donc on sent bien que le
le sujet est craignant nous serions
inquiets aux révolutionne la totalité
des choses alors que nous avons une
bonne base en revanche plus de plus de
de rigueur dans l'application des textes
que nous avons une exigence plus forte
et un renforcement de la gestion de
l'eau par bassin sur la tonalité du
territoire nous semble une des réponses
les plus adaptées
merci merci je vais donner la parole à
Baptiste Julien responsable du pôle eau
à amorce vous avez la parole
je suis d'abord désolé de pas pouvoir
être parmi vous puisque
l'épidémie qui poursuit m'a empêché
d'être à Paris ce jour je présente un
morceau rapidement qui qui consistue qui
consiste à un réseau de de collectivité
avec plus de 1000 adhérents sur
l'ensemble du territoire à différents
échelons de la commune jusqu'à la région
qui vise à être le premier réseau
français d'acteurs d'informations de
partage d'expérience et d'accompagnement
des décideurs en matière de transition
écologique donc on travaille largement
sur les déchets l'énergie et l'eau dont
je suis le responsable
je m'accorde essentiellement avec les
propos qu'on peut tenir mes collègues de
l'année et du sac français de pour l'eau
auquel je suis tout à fait en accord sur
le réveil douloureux qu'on a eu comme
Thierry birlo a pu le dire après
l'histoire de l'exemplarité de
françaises on parle depuis tout à
l'heure beaucoup de questions de
quantitatives mais aujourd'hui sur les
questions de l'eau on a de nombreux
autres enjeux qui sont bien sûr
qualitatifs on parle de pollution
émergente vous avez tous entendu parler
de des métabolites de pesticides qui ont
refait surface son jeu de mot cet été
mais bien sûr aussi tous les impacts du
réchauffement climatique on peut
observer sur nos territoires et l'eau
est au cœur est au centre de de toutes
ces de tous ces effets du réchauffement
climatique donc moi j'aime souvent dire
en
que l'eau est finalement la matrice de
la transition écologique de nos
territoires
dans ce sens
je voudrais aussi faire un petit aparté
sur sur le contexte vous avez tous en
tête la sécheresse de cet été 2022
mes collègues ont cité deux grands
de grands rassemblements que sont les
assises et les Varennes qui ont eu lieu
qui ont pu donner quelques ambitions au
niveau national qui ont se mérite là et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement qui a engagé
le plan o sur la transition écologique
ça c'est au niveau français au niveau
européen on a quand même des directives
qui sont en pleine évolution la
directive sur le résidus aurbaine qui
qui revoit l'ancienne directive de 92
qui a été très bénéfique sur sur le
petit cycle de l'eau au niveau de
l'assainissement qui a permis à
l'essentiel de nos systèmes
d'assainissement de de se mettre en
conformité avec des des enjeux et des
ambitions qui étaient assez fortes
aujourd'hui bien sûr il y a encore un
certain nombre de petits systèmes
d'assainissement qui ne sont pas encore
conformes comme la introduit monsieur le
Président mais on sent une tendance qui
a été dans l'amélioration au niveau de
la directive au potable aussi qui qui a
en cours de transcription au niveau
national on voit de nombreux enjeux
notamment sur tout ce qui est pollution
émergentes
donc on sent bien un besoin de
financement de pour pouvoir faire face à
tous ces nouveaux enjeux mais mais mes
collègues en ont parlé au niveau des
redevances des agences de l'eau mais
aussi on sent bien un enjeu de
d'évolution réglementaire qui est
attendu nous notre position elle est au
niveau de la mort on a réellement besoin
d'un débat d'un débat politique et
parlementaire autour de la question de
l'eau pas pour remettre en cause le la
structuration telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui de gouvernance par bassin
versant qui est exemplaire encore une
fois la France a fait preuve
d'exemplarité sur ce domaine depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années et ce cadre
sécurisant a su faire ses preuves et je
le partage totalement cependant si on on
prend du recul sur l'ensemble de la
gouvernance sur l'ensemble des moyens de
financement et sur la trajectoire c'est
à dire les objectifs aujourd'hui les
exercices de l'eau ont donné des
objectifs de diminution de prélèvement
de 10% dans les 5 ans et de 25% dans les
15 ans aucun texte réglementaire ne
transcrit ses objectifs donc pour nous
il y a un enjeu de de consolider la
structuration de gouvernance et de
financement de l'eau et de rajouter des
objectifs chiffrés tel qu'on peut le
l'observer sur le monde des déchets ou
sur le monde de l'énergie aujourd'hui le
monde de l'eau a très peu d'objectifs
chiffrés et donc la proposition est de
pas d'être ensemble tous ensemble sur la
table pour pour se redonner des des
prospectives mais plutôt pour se mettre
d'accord sur des objectifs à
atteindre dans dans les 5 10 ou 15 ans à
venir
le premier objectif il est dans le
partage de la ressource on a tous cette
en tête ce qui s'est passé et on
souhaite
réfléchir ensemble sur comment bien
répartir l'arceau et je suis totalement
d'accord avec mes confrères sur le fait
que
on a des structures qui existent que ça
soit les âges sur les grands bassins
versants et que ça soit la déclinaison
sur les sages qui sont les sous bassins
hydrographiques
mais ce partage des efforts il faut
qu'il se passe sur
l'ensemble des usages c'est à dire que
si on se donne des objectifs de
réduction que tous les usages respectent
ces objectifs que ce soit le monde
agricole qui est rapidement stigmatisé
mais que ça soit aussi le
bien sûr l'eau potable que ça soit l'eau
industriel et n'oublions pas les
prélèvements qui sont des prélèvements
majeurs on parle pas de consommation
mais de prélèvement qui sont bien
l'énergie nucléaire pour pouvoir
produire notre électricité on se prépare
à des crises et on en a peu parlé dans
les médias cet été que 50% des
prélèvements sont bien
utilisés par le parc nucléaire qui en ce
moment
évoque des perspectives de doublement du
parc donc on se rend bien compte que la
tension et le partage des ressources et
la hiérarchisation des usages va
continuer d'arriver sur la table donc
pour nous il est temps de structurer ce
partage de la ressource et
il nous semble important du coup de
généraliser les sages les sages dont mes
collègues ont parlé aujourd'hui
seulement 50% du territoire est couvert
par un sage un sage dispose à chaque
fois d'une commission locale de l'eau
qui est un outil de concertation entre
l'ensemble des usages sur un périmètre
territorial qui a du sens en termes de
gestion de l'eau puisqu'on ne peut pas
se donner une gouvernance purement
nationale au niveau de l'eau le le
système de gouvernance conclure merci
beaucoup donner la parole à nos
collègues
tout à fait donc on propose la même
chose sur la rationalisation des sages
et l'optimisation là est l'opposabilité
sur le sur les autres outils de
planification on a parlé de PC avec nous
on voudrait aller plus loin aussi sur
sur des objectifs chiffrés que ça soit
sur la réutilisation d'eau usées que
monsieur le Président vous avez évoqué
comment se donner un objectif de
généralisation sur notamment sur le
littoral comment se donner des objectifs
de de des imperméabilisation des des
aires urbaines ou se donner des
objectifs de
d'épandage de produits phytosanitaires
sur les aires d'alimentation des
captages c'est c'est ce type de points
que l'on peut discuter ensemble
merci je vais donner la parole à
Guillaume Chevrollier et puis Hervé
gilet
merci monsieur le Président merci aux
intervenants sur sur ce sujet majeur de
l'eau dans le contexte du changement
climatique vous avez déjà largement
abordé tous les sujets grands cycle le
petit cycle le problématique de la
quantité de la qualité dans le cadre des
auditions budgétaires que je mène chaque
année sur le programme central les
directeurs des agences de l'eau
indiquent chaque année le problème du de
l'insuffisant taux de renouvellement des
infrastructures qui ont un impact
évidemment sur la qualité du service en
termes de fuite mais aussi de rejet non
conforme donc il y a le sujet du plafond
mordant que vous n'avez pas évoqué mais
que nous nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
débattre dans le débat budgétaire qui
qui vient de se terminer au Sénat
d'ailleurs on a on a fait bouger les
lignes puisque vous l'avez indiqué il
faut aussi des moyens financiers pour
mettre en œuvre ces politiques
au-delà de la nécessité de d'une
meilleure coordination et donc ma
première question voilà c'est les
propositions sur les évolutions pour
amener davantage de financement
et la deuxième point c'est même si le
ministre lui n'est pas favorable à une
nouvelle grande loi sur l'eau mais bon
on a vu qu'à morte en propose une clé en
main donc j'aimerais que les différents
intervenants puissent réagir à cette
proposition amorce pourrait en
développer les principales orientations
mais on voit que ce que vous avez pointé
la nécessité d'une planification
territoriale et la nécessité qui est
davantage de d'interconnexion enfin sera
dette d'âge enfin vous avez utilisé
beaucoup d'acronymes les clés le stage
le sage la gemapi par contre vous n'avez
pas parlé du ptgge qui est c'est vrai
que c'est tout nouveau ça vient de
sortir mais c'est quand même aussi ça
vise à avoir une approche glob et qui
peut-être justement pourrait être
intégré dans un dans une dans une
nouvelle loi sur l'eau puisque voilà le
sujet c'est c'est quand même la
résilience de nos territoires par
rapport à ces questions là donc voilà
c'est les observations assez générales
qui peuvent amener à ce que dans votre
deuxième intervention vous puissiez
préciser et réagir par rapport aux
propositions d'amores sur cette nouvelle
nouveau cadre juridique sur l'eau je
vous remercie merci la parole est arrivé
merci président et merci d'avoir répondu
à la proposition que j'avais pu faire
mais comme d'autres collègues
effectivement de faire le point avec
Thierry Burlot au niveau du CFE Frédéric
et puis monsieur Forel au niveau de la
naine pourquoi parce que justement on
arrive à un moment où vous avez mené
ainsi que de travaux particulièrement
intéressant puisque l'ANEB vient de
sortir son livre bleu qui est un
document je trouve stratégique
intéressant à poser aujourd'hui par
rapport à par rapport à ces sujets et
puis le CFE a mené tout un cycle aussi
de conférences et d'échanges pour voir
si nous devions aller ou pas vers des
évolutions législatives et ça constitue
une base de travail qui est
particulièrement intéressante donc j'ai
le plaisir de vous retrouver peut-être à
ce stade par rapport à un exposé assez
complet que vous avez pu faire
allez peut-être un peu plus loin sur
certaines questions tout d'abord sur les
EP
je suis entièrement d'accord sur le fait
que il constitue aujourd'hui
véritablement les structures à la fois
politique et techniques pour mener un
ensemble de programmes d'actions
souhaitez-vous aller aujourd'hui aussi
plus loin dans la reconnaissance des
EPTB d'abord un les EPTB ne constituent
pas un label en soi c'est à dire que une
mobilise certainement des financements
mais au même titre que d'autres
syndicats ni plus ni moins faut-il aller
plus loin dans la reconnaissance des
EPTB et quelle vision de la
planification vous avez sur le
déploiement des optb
on a eu un dialogue politique pour ce
qui fait que on peut avoir de la
différenciation territoriale mais
jusqu'à quel niveau si on veut avoir une
vraie planification en tant que tel et
ce qu'il faut pas avoir une vision plus
globale aujourd'hui sur le développement
des EPTB vous avez moins parlé
aujourd'hui des épages il y avait une
forme d'articulation entre les EPTB et
les épages peut-être que vous pourriez
justement sans doute le préciser par
rapport à ça autre sujet que vous vous
avez vous avez moins évoqué sur la
gestion de la ressource sur la gestion
des nappes c'est aussi un sujet qui est
très particulier une nappe de surface
les nappes profondes différençage
également sont mises en oeuvre dans ce
cas de figure et elle nous renvoie aussi
à des qualités de politique d'urbanisme
qui ont été abordés dans la liaison
Scott et pluie puisque le but du jeu
entre le petit cycle et les grands
cycles c'est de gérer au mieux le fil de
l'eau et un des sujets en termes de
stockage qui apparaissent et de
reconstituer des zones humides de les
diversifier et c'est sans doute un des
éléments de stockage parallèle que l'on
peut constituer aujourd'hui et peut-être
que vous pourriez nous donner quelques
éléments complémentaires sur ces sujets
là enfin dernier point sur ce stage et
sera dette effectivement il y a un vrai
une vraie question en termes de
planification aujourd'hui qui font
interroger mais qui nous renvoie aussi
sur les contrats de plan états région et
aussi ce qui nous manque en termes
d'outils les contrats de plan
interrégionaux qui aujourd'hui sont un
peu en stand-by contrôle plan et ta
région parce qu'il faudrait à mon sens
je voudrais avoir votre avis sur le
sujet instituer aussi les politiques
entre l'État les collectivités
territoriales et ensuite les opérateurs
notamment avec les CPER ils
travaillaient
des conventions territoriales avec
éventuellement les départements et les
autres collectivités pour déployer en
subsidiarité ces politiques donc là
également si vous pouvez m'apporter
quelques éléments d'analyse sur ce sujet
je vous remercie merci je vais donner la
parole à Cyril pelvin et après monsieur
Denis et après vous répondrez
merci monsieur le Président et merci aux
intervenants pour la qualité de leur
intervention donc en ce qui concerne ma
question le 9 novembre les sept comités
de bassins sont réunis avec la
secrétaire d'étages chargée de
l'écologie cette rencontre constituée le
premier point d'étape pour définir la
feuille de route un gouvernementale pour
l'eau et dont la mise en œuvre devrait
débuter au premier trimestre 2023
unanimement il a été constaté nécessité
impérieuse d'agir plus rapidement et
plus fortement pour mettre en place des
solutions structurelles d'adaptation au
changement climatique outre la nécessité
d'investir davantage de lever les Francs
organisationnels et de mobiliser des
acteurs locaux plusieurs pistes d'action
ont été soulevées en particulier
accompagner l'agriculture pour la rendre
plus sobre en eau porter l'effort sur
l'organisation du partage de l'eau et
rendent les espaces urbains plus
résilients cependant les comités de
bassins sont accordés sur le fait que
les actions ne seront à elle seule pas
suffisantes sur les territoires et ont
reconnu que la mobilisation de nouvelles
ressources en eau sera nécessaire
qu'il s'agisse de transfert d'eau de
stockage de réutilisation des eaux usées
traitées tout en soulignant que cette
mobilisation devra se faire dans le
respect des milieux naturels être adapté
aux spécificités des territoires et
passer par un processus de concertation
autour du partage de l'eau entre tous
les usages or en ce qui concerne le
stockage de l'eau je pense en
particulier au contenu colinéaires et le
président forêt le connaissent c'est un
sujet épiné en Haute-Savoie et bassine
malgré la mise en oeuvre des
recommandations l'obtention des
autorisations environnementales et
malgré le fait que très peu de conflits
d'usage soient constatés l'acceptabilité
de cette solution est de plus en plus
difficile et les recours contentieux et
les aides se multiplient je m'interroge
donc sur la manière dont nous pourrions
rationaliser cette pratique mais aussi
apaiser le débat des pistes ont-elles
été explorées pour se faire et pour que
l'opinion publique comprenne mieux les
enjeux liés au stockage existe-t-il par
exemple un guide des bonnes pratiques à
destination des collectivités je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur Denis merci monsieur le
Président je suis ici sur votre gauche
je souhaite merci Monsieur pour pour vos
interventions je voudrais aborder deux
sujets concernant la gestion de l'eau à
ces techniques et inclure plus générale
le premier sujet d'actualité m'amène à
poser la question effectivement un peu
technique de ce qui est potable ou non
en effet les ARS recherchent
régulièrement de nouvelles traces de
pesticides lors de contrôle sanitaire
mais la limite de qualité
0,1 microgramme par litre pour les
métabolites est uniquement une valeur
environnementale et non une valeur
sanitaire établie au niveau européen
une eau contenant des teneurs en
pesticides supérieur à 0,1 microgramme
par litre est qualifié de non-conformes
au regard de cette valeur
environnementale mais elle n'est pas
forcément impropre à la consommation
ces incohérences de lecture on les
trouve aussi d'ailleurs dans les
réglementations concernant la valeur
sanitaire maximale fixée par l'ancêtre
comment messieurs uniformiser ses
réglementations et rassurer
consommateurs et collectivités sur la
qualité de l'euro la deuxième question
est effectivement plus plus générale
puisqu'elle concerne le partage de l'eau
dont on a déjà beaucoup parlé et
notamment monsieur Burlot on le sait
l'usage de l'eau pour l'agriculture
notamment va s'intensifier mais là aussi
des incohérences se font jour je vais
prendre un exemple précis chez moi sans
liste le sec ça tombe bien pour parler
de de l'eau c'est un village du
département de la Somme trois forages
agricoles ont été réalisés en 2021 alors
que le captage de la commune est
particulièrement vulnérable aux
variations de nappe la communauté de
commun n'a pas été consulté dans la
procédure d'autorisation des services
d'autorisation des services de l'État et
la commune on a été informé mais sans
pouvoir de décision selon vous messieurs
au-delà du problème de partage de cette
ressource en nous entre l'agriculture
l'industrie et les particuliers
quels moyens de contrôle supplémentaire
complémentaire doivent être mises en
place pour donner un petit peu plus de
pouvoir aux collectivités politiques
merci je vous propose de vous répartir
les réponses pour parce que j'ai encore
cette demande de parole donc allez-y
peut-être moins en réaction là à la
réunion des présidents de
bassin mais Thierry complétera mais il
se trouve que vous avez devant vous
Thierry et moi-même avons été sollicités
par le
Conseil national de l'eau et son
président Jean le nez pour qu'au
président un des groupes de travail dans
le cadre du Plan o qui devrait faire
l'objet d'annonce gouvernementale nous
dit-on fin janvier bon
et nous avons acquis ces années durant
quelques expériences
des sujets de l'eau et en particulier on
a fait référence aux assises 1 et 2
petits et grands cycle de l'eau suivie
assez rapidement du varen dans la foulée
nous nous y sommes engagés mais nous
avons tenté voilà humblement d'ouvrir le
dialogue dans le cadre de nos groupes de
travail parce que l'expérience vous avez
quelques peu frustrés si j'ose
m'exprimer de la sorte puisque la
méthode est toujours un peu la même
d'ailleurs elle se ressemble
se ressemblent beaucoup
il faut aller vite
pas plus de deux à trois réunions de
groupe de travail
pour ensuite passer éventuellement à des
annonces vous comprendrez bien que face
aux enjeux que l'on évoque ce matin
je ne suis pas de ceux qui pensent que
la réunionite est forcément gage de
réussite mais parfois savoir donner du
temps au temps pour reprendre une
expression qui n'est pas de moi vous
l'aurez compris peut s'avérer somme
toute un peu utile et que en matière
d'eau notamment ça nous semble important
vu des enjeux c'est pour ça que nous
insistons vraiment beaucoup auprès de
vous sur l'absolu nécessité d'ailleurs
parmi toutes les interventions on le
voit bien quand vous renvoyez à la
réalité que chacun d'entre vous vit à
l'échelle de son territoire en termes de
conflits d'usage
les forages agricoles ici les bassines
colinaires bref on pourrait multiplier
les exemples parce que on est bon on ne
parle pas d'autres bon on voit bien que
s'il n'y a pas un document
partager à l'échelle des territoires
par l'ensemble des acteurs qui
établissent les éléments stratégiques et
de planification à moyen et long terme
nous allons être amenés et conduit à
gérer les uns et les autres au coup par
coup souvent dans l'urgence et du coup
souvent dans les tensions qui risquent
de s'exacerber des sujets dont on
connaît par ailleurs globalement en tout
cas les tenants et les aboutissants bien
et aujourd'hui forcer de constater que
l'ensemble du territoire national n'est
pas couvert par ces éléments de
planification et donc pour nous il est
important nécessaire que l'ensemble du
territoire en soi pourvu premier élément
et deuxième élément j'insiste là-dessus
parce que on a beaucoup parlé de la
question du bassin versant et je crois
que chacun ici dans ce que j'ai pu
percevoir aussi bien des propos du
président que de l'ensemble des
sénateurs qui se sont la maîtrise qui se
sont exprimées jusque là tout le monde
considère que ça c'est un élément
fondamental or je pense je vous le dis
nous le constatons parfois sur nos
territoires
le fait encore une fois d'avoir institué
la gemmes que nous ne remettons pas en
cause son nom bien mais qui renvoie au
bloc communal ce que nous approuvons par
ailleurs mais qui ne fait pas l'objet
d'une d'un dispositif de gouvernance à
l'échelle du bassin versant et c'est là
que de notre point de vue et page et le
PTB
sont nécessaires
non pas comme un frein ou un élément
supplémentaire mais comme une garantie
pour les élus locaux et l'ensemble des
partis prenantes à l'échelle du bassin
versant que notamment l'ingénierie et en
maîtrise d'ouvrage il y a une garantie
par une gouvernance à cette échelle
d'intervention cohérente planifiée
en soutien aux collectivités locales et
surtout qui s'assure qu'une intervention
à Lamont et qu'une intervention à Laval
doivent se compléter et non
éventuellement créer des difficultés
supplémentaires et ce que je dis là
au-delà des questions par exemple de la
prévention du risque inondation vaut
également sur les questions de soutien
des tirage mais j'aimerais qu'on y
revienne parce que on évoque beaucoup la
gymnapi je voudrais dire juste deux mots
brièvement sur le or j'ai Mappy
pardonnez-moi et et donc garantissent la
sol la vérité qui pour nous est un
élément fondamental moi j'ai présidé
scène grand lac scène grand lac c'est
c'est le PTB dont l'historiquement la
vocation était de protéger la zone danse
francilienne bien j'ai eu
c'est chez nous si j'ose dire parce que
ça s'étend bon c'était établissement non
mais juste parce que je vraiment je suis
un militant de cette cause là quand j'ai
pris la présidence de cet établissement
inutile de vous dire que sur les
territoires en particulier ceux où
étaient implantés nos lacs réservoir
le traumatisme était encore dans
certains de ces territoires énormes
énormes en particulier si je peux me
permettre du côté de la Marne et de la
Haute-Marne parce que le lac du Der a vu
trois villages être enfin disparaître et
rayé de la carte bien
j'ai tenu mais vraiment à associer à la
gouvernance l'ensemble des territoires
or je rappelle que ça n'était pas le cas
jusque là puisque seuls les quatre
départements constituant la petite
couronne
bien compris participer de la
gouvernance or depuis tous les
territoires à proximité immédiate de nos
ouvrages participent à la gouvernance et
je suis profondément convaincu encore
une fois que c'est à l'échelle des
territoires et à l'échelle du bassin
versant que les choses doivent se jouer
donc très clairement oui nous pensons
qu'il faut
alors ou renforcer ou obliger ou
favoriser je ne sais quelle méthode ou
quel terme retenir mais en tout cas
l'obligation de couvrir le territoire de
documents de planification et d'outils
de gouvernance à l'échelle du bassin
versant qui garantissent à l'ensemble
des collectivités que la cohérence de
l'intervention leur garantira les
meilleurs résultats possibles en
concernant la question du grand cycle du
grand cycle de l'eau dernier point le
hors gemapi j'attire votre attention les
eaux de ruissellement
bon voilà une fois qu'on l'a posé une
question chacun fait comme il peut sur
le sujet mais en réalité personne ne
sait exactement qui doit faire pas faire
comment jusqu'où et là aussi à quelle
échelle voilà et la question
paradoxalement pareil un peu aujourd'hui
orpheline qui est la question du soutien
des tiens en période de sécheresse
ne figure pas dans la gemmie or chacun
le sait les scientifiques y compris le
disent on aura vraisemblablement des
intensifications d'épisode d'inondation
avec des effets bien plus importants
qu'on a pu les connaître et les derniers
exemples en Europe de l'Est en témoigne
on a on dépasse parfois les centenaires
dans un contexte d'urbanisation et
technologique du par ailleurs nous
rendent paradoxalement plus vulnérable
que nous ne l'étions même à Paris en
1910 ne serait-ce que les questions des
réseaux et à l'inverse une
intensification des épisodes de
sécheresse et donc de nécessité de forme
de soutien des tirages or ces deux
éléments et les autres ruissellement
vous voyez aussi ce que cela induit
parfois sur les territoires en termes de
dégâts et d'un profil
d'approvisionnement y compris des terres
agricoles par endroits sont l'un des
angles un peu morts puisque
le constituant n'étant pas partie
prenante de la gélatine en termes et
compris de financement bref mais en tout
cas je voulais aussi attirer votre
attention monsieur Burlot en quelques
minutes pour qu'on puisse parce que j'ai
vite interventions je vais essayer
on a beaucoup travaillé au Cercle
français de l'eau et d'ailleurs je vous
invite madame et messieurs les sénateurs
à vous rapprocher du CFE si ça vous
intéresse parce qu'on essaye de
réfléchir collectivement à toutes ces
questions et quand je dis collectivement
c'est aussi bien avec nos amis de l'AMF
de l'ARF de la DCF des entreprises d'EDF
pour essayer collectivement de faire des
propositions et depuis quelques mois on
travaille sur faut-il une nouvelle loi
sur l'eau alors nous à l'inverse
d'amorce on dit attention surtout pas
problème c'est pas un problème de
renforcer de la réglementation là où il
y a plutôt un système qui qui est assez
solide le problème c'est de se dire où
c'est que ça va pas et qu'est-ce qu'on
peut améliorer collectivement
c'est plutôt dans cet état d'esprit que
l'on est et le grand soir on y croit pas
trop
moi je pense que l'une des difficultés
qu'on a pour répondre à Monsieur
chevronnier c'est qu'on se comprend pas
le monde de l'Aune ne sait plus parler
aux autres politiques
et alors en complexifie parce que vous
avez parlé de ça de stage de
ptgge de PTB des pages n'attendez les
gens vous disent mais d'abord c'est quoi
tout ça
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on peut parler
français un petit peu là parce que je
vous ai pas parlé d'achemuk et tout ça
ou du pecs moi je viens de voter un
stage
je crois qu'il fait 10 kg de papier
personne va le lire
et j'ai dit en plaisantant à mon
directeur d'agence de l'eau il faudrait
qu'on écrive un stage pour les nuls
non mais je plaisante pas on ne se
comprend plus on sait plus de quoi on
parle donc revenons à des choses simples
et je pense que c'est important je
profite pour dire que heureusement qu'on
avait des retenues c'était
parce qu'on est en train de se dire il
faut surtout pas de retenue etc mais
heureusement qu'on en avait cet été
et je vais même aller plus loin
attention à toucher
à EDF et à l'hydroélectricité
parce que là il y a un vrai sujet
parce que la mise en concurrence peut
détruire un système qui aujourd'hui
fonctionne très bien hier on a une
présentation
de ce qui s'est passé sur la Durance
grâce au soutien des tirages effectué
par EDF et ses barrages hydrauliques et
la cohérence d'action publique qu'il y a
là
imaginez demain une mise en concurrence
qui pourrait ruiner tous ses efforts
donc j'en profite pour vous dire ça
c'est très important cette histoire
d'hydroélectricité et et de savoir faire
français autour de EDF
j'essaie d'aller au plus vite dans mes
réponses parce que c'est tellement
compliqué
vous dire ça ne souligne c'est chez nous
passer chez nous c'est sur l'arbre
Bretagne vous savez que le comité de
bassin que je préside qui regroupe 180
personnes
moi je suis à Rémi n'a même pas été
sollicité sur le sujet de sainte-solide
il faut le faire quand même
on a mis à feu et on sent un territoire
et le comité de bassin qui est censé
appliquer le stage réfléchir à ces
questions n'a même pas été sollicité
donc il y a quelque chose qui fonctionne
pas quand même il y a quelque chose qui
fonctionne pas alors pourquoi ça
fonctionne pas parce que chacun
travaille dans son coin
et aujourd'hui ce qui se passe à Sainte
Soline
n'est que le résultat
d'un non dialogue dans les territoires
et d'une certaine forme moi je suis très
surpris de voir des gens très modérés
avoir des positions très très fortes sur
ce sujet sans même connaître le
fonctionnement de la bassine rien
c'est-à-dire que on ne sait même pas
comment ça fonctionne alors que sur le
fond c'est un truc intéressant mais on
arrive même pas vous l'avez dit à
expliquer ce qu'on va faire
alors moi je vais vous dire sainte
Soline comme les autres ça pourra pas se
faire s'il y a pas un État fort et des
territoires à côté fort parce que vous
avez entendu beaucoup d'élus soutenir
Sainte-Soline
personne personne n'ose aller sur le
sujet
c'est tellement compliqué
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut que
le projet soit public et sous contrôle
public parce que sinon c'est une forme
d'accaparation d'une activité sur un
bien commun
et pour vous dire mon sentiment je pense
que le stockage ne peut passer que par
une gestion publique et collective et
multi-usage
sinon ça sera de la préparation
nous faisons très attention alors j'ai
eu la Coop de l'eau parce qu'on a pris
une motion c'est le sénateur on a pris
une motion l'autre jour au comité de
bassin que l'État d'ailleurs n'a pas
voté
incroyable condamnant les violences
rappelant le dialogue et disons qu'il
fallait qu'on travaille ensemble c'était
quand même
le Béaba dans l'État membre du comité de
bassin c'est abstenu rendez compte
rendez compte c'est incroyable ce truc
mais enfin bref
c'est incroyable
encore une fois je pense que
il va falloir partager
et qui dit partage dit attention donc il
y en a pour tout le monde tout le monde
va devoir faire des efforts y compris de
consommateurs
l'industriel mais il faut des lieux de
partage de concertation et de projets
collectifs et ça ça peut se faire que si
on a un état qui est fort bien sûr mais
aussi des territoires qui se mobilisent
sur le sujet
et l'une des dernières conférences qu'on
a fait sur le cercle français de l'eau
c'était de dire est-ce qu'on va avoir le
courage politique d'y aller
parce que la question elle est là
parce que derrière les questions de
quantité il y a les questions de qualité
et moins vous avez d'eau plus elle est
dégradée
et j'ai un élève qui connaît bien la
région Bretagne et Nadège
j'ai fait le calcul en Bretagne
aujourd'hui on consomme 240 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau
on annonce la Bretagne à 4 millions
d'habitants
et ben il nous manque entre 50 et 60
millions de mètres cubes d'eau c'est la
consommation totale du département des
Côtes-d'Armor
et vous savez la Bretagne c'est le
massif armoricain il y a pas d'eau
souterraine
alors on peut dire plein de choses des
solutions fondées sur la nature on peut
tout ça ça sera à faire préserver les
zones humides etc etc mais ceci dit au
bout du bout
et voilà stocker l'eau parce que l'eau
si vous n'avez pas c'est le
développement économique que vous
impactez c'est la capacité de construire
ou de développer vos citer qui est en
cause c'est la capacité d'épurer c'est
la capacité de produire de l'énergie
même si encore une fois j'ai une
différence d'approche avec armorce parce
que la centrale nucléaire est capte
l'eau évidemment mais la rejette
donc il faut faire attention elle a 4
mais la rejette donc vous voyez il faut
que collectivement on on porte ce
dossier je crois que la réponse ne peut
être que collective et pour répondre à
Monsieur sénateur normalement il y a des
périmètres de protection
la règle veut qu'il y ait des périmètres
de protection de captage autour des
forages et que les prélèvements qui
pourraient avoir autour serait sous
contrôle mais là encore une fois ça
montre la faiblesse des dispositifs
réglementaires passent à l'enjeu qu'on
vit et sur les pesticides je suis
d'accord avec vous mais on a quand même
un système sanitaire qui fonctionne pas
trop mal en France l'eau du robinet
aujourd'hui elle est quand même somme
toute de très bonne qualité et et et ça
on finit par l'oublier quoi et je pense
que le débat qui a eu sur les normes sur
les métabolites de pesticides nous a
fait à tous très mal
et encore une fois ça montre la
difficulté qu'on a aujourd'hui entre
l'application de la DCE l'ARS l'ancêtre
les nouvelles normes on sort des seuils
après on revienne dessus parce qu'on se
rend compte de la difficulté de les
mettre en oeuvre mais entre-temps on a
fait peur à nos consommateurs
on a fait peur à nos consommateurs donc
je pense qu'il faut aussi là
dire les choses l'eau au robinet elle
est de qualité on a on a des
collectivités qui s'affairent on a des
entreprises qui savent faire on a un
prix de l'homme ce président qui est
somme toute acceptable au regard
vous savez l'autre jour
pour faire le lien entre haut et énergie
j'ai trouvé ça intéressant il y a
quelqu'un qui disait vous ouvrez le
robinet
un mètre cube d'eau bon vous allez le
payer deux trois euros le mètre cube
mais vous faites rentrer dans la maison
chaque année
70 tonnes de ressources naturelles
parfois
c'est une tonne vous faites rentrer 70
tonnes vous vous rendez compte l'énergie
et l'usage que vous apportez au
quotidien et tout ça pour 3 euros le
mètre cube
je crois qu'il faut revenir des choses
simples comme ça
merci je voudrais pas faire un mauvais
jeu de mots il faut être sage quoi
Monsieur Bigot
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur pour ces informations moi je
suis élu d'un département qui est
traversé par la Loire et comme bon
nombre de départements
dans cette salle
on a connu une sécheresse extrême cet
été les tirages de la Loire est bas
beaucoup de cours d'eau sont à sec une
majorité de stations hydrométrique
présente des débits inférieurs de 75%
par rapport au normal ces évolutions
sont malheureusement conformes aux
prévisions des experts du BRGM qui
estiment que le débit des cours d'eau
devrait diminuer de 10 à 40% d'ici 2070
on voit que l'eau constitue un marqueur
incontournable du dérèglement climatique
qui mérite toute notre attention donc on
a bien entendu vos explications et mais
aujourd'hui l'heure va être à faire des
propositions
avez-vous travaillé à la création
d'outils communs de prospective
permettant d'anticiper les futurs
membres d'eau à court et à moyen terme
et d'autre part lors du dernier congrès
de la mort ce Monsieur le Représentant
d'amorce pourra nous répondre Bérengère
Couillard secrétaire d'État à l'écologie
a annoncé une feuille de route
apparaître en janvier prochain qui
s'inspirera des travaux des assises de
l'eau ce sera intéressant de connaître
les propositions qui seront formulées
est-ce que vous en connaissez les
grandes orientations de ce document
avez-vous été consulté par le ministère
ce sont des des approches que les
acteurs locaux attendent avec impatience
et puis je voudrais vous poser une
question quel est votre approche d'une
gestion sobre de l'eau parce
qu'aujourd'hui se pose la question de la
gestion de l'eau qui devient de plus en
plus rare alors vous avez parlé des
petits cycles du Grand Cycle sur les
petits cycles notamment on propose aux
particuliers l'accompagnement et est-ce
qu'il on propose un accompagnement
spécifique aux particuliers qui
souhaitent réutiliser leurs eaux
usagées récupérer l'eau de pluie ou
encore réduire l'imperméabilisation
est-ce qu'il y a là-dessus des travaux
qui sont en cours et des plaquettes
pédagogiques en cours de réalisation ça
me paraît important et puis sur le grand
cycle de l'eau on pourra pas évacuer la
question des modèles économiques vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure d'un bien
commun de l'eau et sur les modèles
économiques il y a notamment la question
agricole est-ce que ces questions sont
abordées dans vos organismes pour gérer
au mieux la ressource en eau dans les
années qui viennent je vous remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur gold
merci monsieur le Président merci aux
différents intervenants dans un contexte
où le législateur a fixé un rythme
d'artificialisation des sols divisé par
deux pour 2030 on a aujourd'hui
finalement deux visions d'aménagement
avec d'un côté des collectivités plutôt
rurales qui s'emploie contourner
l'obligation en fait par la loi climat
et résidence avec le motif de continuer
à bénéficier d'un certain nombre de
permis de construire pour accueillir de
nouveaux ménages synonyme de maintien ou
de développement de population
et puis d'autres collectivités plusieurs
bennes qui vont en profiter pour
reprendre la main peut-être sur la
maîtrise de leur fonciers avec des
aménagements plus sobre et une politique
de logements qui intègre finalement une
stratégie de sol vivant et une réelle
réflexion sur l'eau et la biodiversité
alors la gestion de la compétence home
elle est donc très liée à ces stratégies
d'aménagement
les dernières élections municipales ont
été l'occasion justement avec de
nouveaux élus de mettre à jour de
nouvelles initiatives et de nouveaux
projets de territoire parmi eux parmi
ces projets de territoires nouveaux
voyez-vous de nouvelles pratiques qui
associent plus les acteurs de l'eau avec
des architectes des paysagistes des
urbanistes qui et qui envisagent la
gestion de l'eau de manière globale
c'est à dire des aménagements qui
peuvent qui prennent en compte la
protection de la ressource jusqu'aux
différents usages en passant par la
distribution et la prévention des
inondations et voir la gestion des eaux
pluviales
en un mot c'est quoi pour vous
finalement aujourd'hui un aménagement
réussi merci
monsieur le Président oui tout d'abord
j'ai apprécié le
pragmatisme de notre président Thierry
Burlot sur les problèmes de l'eau
j'avais un certain de questions à poser
tout d'abord sur la continuité
écologique de nos rivières puisque notre
collègue Guillaume chevrolier avait
déposé un amendement sur la protection
des moulins et de ce fait donc les
agences de l'eau aujourd'hui refusent
d'aider à leur mise aux normes et
notamment les passes à poissons en leur
disant que qui se débrouille puisque ils
ont voulu
être protégés maintenant comme c'est du
domaine privé on ne les aide plus ça
c'était la première question maintenant
il y a un problème aussi sur la
gouvernance a été dit on est dans une
grande complexité
au niveau des de la gestion de l'eau
avec les clés les sages les pages le
ptge il y a une complexité et d'autre
part on est c'est très chronophage
aujourd'hui s'occuper de l'eau on voit
bien qu'elle multitude de réunions c'est
pas mon président qui va qui va me
contredire je note qu'il y a aujourd'hui
et ça c'est le point de vue d'un certain
nombre d'élus une sur-repréesation des
organismes et associations
environnementales qui sont financés par
les collectivités qui ont à la fois des
moyens mais aussi du temps par rapport
aux élus pour se consacrer
au domaine de l'eau ils sont très
présents et je pense que il faudrait
revoir la représentation
au niveau de la gouvernance des agences
de l'eau
concernant le
périmètre géographique et le périmètre
politique qui correspond pas aux
périmètre politique et je rejoins tout à
fait des propos de de Thierry Burlot
on ne peut pas continuer à avoir des
bassins qui représentent comme l'agence
de Loire Bretagne qui représente 30 % du
territoire avec un budget de 380
millions d'euros et des bassins qui sont
beaucoup plus petits et qui ont le
double ou le triple de de financement et
je pense que il va falloir qu'on étudie
la possibilité d'une solidarité
nationale de l'eau et peut-être une
péréquation je sais pas comment donc par
lequel moyen mais je pense que ça me
paraît important
sur l'effort du Grand Cycle il est
évident que il faut travailler sur la
sobriété mais moi je rappelle quand même
que il y a un sujet qui est inquiétant
puisque on a aujourd'hui
un milliard de mètres cubes d'eau qui
est perdu par les canalisations d'eau
potable
ça représente pour une comparaison qui
me paraît intéressante 2000 bassines du
type de sainte Soline 2000 bassine
donc il faut relativiser un petit peu
les choses et je pense qu'il on a
intérêt à revoir un petit peu les
problèmes des retenus et ça c'est vrai
que les a laissé tomber moi je pense au
grand barrage aussi est-ce qu'il va pas
falloir
refaire une politique de grand barrage
on a abandonné chambourchard sur le Cher
et une époque et aujourd'hui cette année
on n'aurait pas eu de problème si on
avait eu ce grand barrage sur les
conflits d'usage
c'est qui ont été évoqués on fait
beaucoup de concertation on fait
beaucoup de communication il y a du
dialogue c'est vrai que le problème
c'est que on a parfois du dialogue de
sourd et de malentendants parce que on a
une certaine catégorie et je pense aux
addistes mais aussi aux écologistes
radicaux que de toute façon ne
changeront jamais d'avis sur le sujet de
l'eau ils ont leur point de vue et on
pas les convaincre comment on fait moi
j'avoue que je suis assez
dubitatif là-dessus le partage de l'eau
c'est vrai que
il faut le faire mais il faut qu'au
dessus on soit entendu par les uns par
les autres la gemmapique a été évoquée
par Monsieur molossi moi je vous
rappelle quand même qu'au Sénat on a
réussi à voter un amendement avec Madame
goureau et c'est moi qui était
dépositeur de cette amendement pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
solidarité par bassin et par
bassin versant puisqu'on a proposé de
faire une expérimentation avec les
établissements publics et notamment PL
le l'établissement public Loire qui
aujourd'hui refuse
cette expérience donc je pense qu'il va
falloir passer à l'obligation parce
qu'on ne peut pas continuer à travailler
avec du saucissonnage comme vous l'avez
dit sur des basses inversants ou les
EPCI qui ont les moyens feront des
digues les autres pas donc ça veut dire
que c'est complètement incohérent et on
pourra pas travailler sur une protection
des des berges de nos bassin versants
donc voilà moi j'avais toutes ces
questions
et à certains de réponses que nous avons
pu faire au Sénat moi pour moi l'eau
doit payer l'eau ça c'est un principe de
base on l'a démontré en essayant
d'augmenter le le fond mordant qui à mon
avis va être rejeté et était rejeté
peut-être déjà par le 49-3 d'après ce
que j'ai compris mais si on veut avoir
des moyens il faut aussi que les agences
de l'eau puissent avoir fomborant qui
soit un peu
surélevé puisque la biodiversité
l'ofb est financé par les agences de
l'eau et c'est 400 millions d'euros
quand même qui sont
financés par les agences de l'eau sans
moyens supplémentaires
merci Rémy la parole est à Madame
Bonnefoy
merci le président l'association amorce
a formulé lors de son dernier congrès
plusieurs propositions intéressantes
comme la mise en place d'une filière
repos en vue de faire face au cou du
traitement des pesticides agricoles
c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse
particulièrement au vu des travaux que
j'ai déjà pu mener dans le cadre d'une
mission d'information sur le sujet qui
plaidait pour un encadrement plus strict
de l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires j'ai d'ailleurs défendu
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 l'idée d'une
redevance pour pollution diffuse pour
soutenir le service public de la gestion
de l'eau donc pour le moment le
gouvernement semble dépassé par le sujet
alors que pleuvent les études alarmantes
sur la qualité de l'eau présentant des
résidus de pesticides parfois interdits
depuis plus de 20 ans comme la trazine
et c'est le cas dans mon département en
terre viticole en particulier
tout à l'heure également et est-ce que
vous réfléchissez à un nouveau
partenariat
merci pour vos réponses merci Madame
Préville merci président merci d'abord
pour vous présenter alors je vais aller
dans le même sens de ma collègue et je
tiens à dire d'abord que je suis
représente le Sénat au comité de bassin
à nougaronne et effectivement alors on a
une un comité de bassin demain matin
auquel je participerai pour déjà dire
qu'effectivement ce que vous avez
mentionné et particulièrement prégnant
en Occitanie notamment avec -20% de
pluvieux métrie déjà acté ce qui sera le
cas sur tout le territoire national mais
qui sera beaucoup plus important chez
nous et avec des températures de la
Garonne qui flirtent avec les 30 degrés
tous les étés ce qui rend évidemment
très difficile le fonctionnement de la
centrale de Golfech puisque si l'eau est
prélevée elle sert à refroidir et elle
ressort plus chaude et que donc si sa
température est trop élevée on ne peut
pas refroidir correctement une centrale
nucléaire donc il y a également un vrai
sujet alors moi je vous voulez revenir
sur la question de la qualité et
effectivement comme ma collègue pour
vous dire que ce que l'on ne recherche
pas comme polluant comme micropolluant
on ne risque pas de le trouver
effectivement et que la chimie c'est
énormément développé ces dernières
années les mises sur le marché de
nouveaux nouvelles molécules chimiques
sont en exposition sont en expansion
exponentielle il y a nous avons réalisé
avec le comité de bassin un colloque sur
les micropolluants de l'eau le 11
juillet dernier à Bordeaux et donc les
interventions des professeurs de chimie
nous ont informé bien de ce sujet qui
est un sujet qui est un impensé jusqu'à
présent et qui est un sujet émergent
effectuant dont il faut absolument se
préoccuper et certes la qualité de l'eau
est bonne mais
certaines choses ne sont pas recherchées
et puisque j'ai fait un travail sur la
pollution plastique notamment les
microplastiques et il faudra aussi
pencher il faudra trouver des
financements il faudra trouver des
moyens pour
faire en sorte que cela n'arrive pas
chez nos chez les consommateurs cette
eau polluée avec ses particules et donc
certainement des moyens financiers à
mettre en oeuvre et puis également du
législatif à faire pour limiter cela
mais j'ai un autre sujet aussi à vous
soumettre puisque je reviens d'un
déplacement avec le Sénat au Maroc et
notamment puisque nous avons rencontré
le ministre de l'équipement et de l'eau
donc il y a un ministre de l'équipement
et de l'eau au Maroc et c'est vrai que
son intervention quand nous l'avons
rencontré était particulièrement
intéressante pour nous puisque au Maroc
il y a par exemple une politique
nationale générale sur tout le
territoire de l'eau avec une gestion et
c'est ce qui correspond au grand cycle
de l'eau et peut-être qu'effectivement
nous pourrions envisager nous à l'avenir
alors ça va être très complexe je vous
l'accorde une politique chapeau en
quelque sorte de l'eau alors comment la
mettre en oeuvre puisque nous avons nous
allons avoir des communes des
territoires qui vont subir de grandes
sécheresse il y a la question des
soutiens des tirages donc
approvisionnement nous et soutien des
tirages et peut-être qu'il faudra que
l'on mette plus en avant le fait que
l'eau c'est vitale effectivement pour
l'agriculture pour tout le monde pour
les industriels également et quel
quelque sorte mettre en avant cette
priorité absolue alors certes cet été
c'était une petite alerte mais
l'alerte elle est là et peut-être que
nous aurons à changer beaucoup de choses
sur notre politique de l'eau comment
voyez-vous ça et comment envisagez-vous
alors à la fois l'histoire de ces
micropolluants de l'eau
quel est votre sensibilisation sur ce
sujet là et sur
la mise en oeuvre d'une politique enfin
moi je l'appelle comme ça une politique
chapeau parce que je trouve que ce
serait c'est ce serait marqué et puis et
puis ce serait faire face à la réalité
qui est devant nous voilà merci la
parole est à Madame
monsieur le Président
effectivement on va avoir des objectifs
en termes de transition écologique et
pour atteindre les baisses de
prélèvement
il va falloir un consensus sur l'eau ce
qui représente un enjeu national et
territorial cela ne va pas passer par un
effort de démocratisation d'éducation et
de communication ciblée et continue sur
les usages et les priorisations tout à
l'heure on a parlé d'un stage pour les
nuls donc ma question est la suivante en
fait selon vous comment rend-on plus
compréhensible et lisible d'une
politique publique aussi essentielle que
celle-ci comment associe-t-on au mieux
l'ensemble d'une population à la gestion
durable de l'eau et avez-vous pu
identifier des pratiques vertueuses dans
la matière et au niveau du bassin de vie
et au niveau des collectivités merci
merci chers la parole est à Fabien je
n'ai et après
madame filleul et vous aurez le loisir
de l'éponge il faut qu'on ait terminé à
12h15 parce qu'après j'ai des questions
diverses
bien alors je vais très vite monsieur le
Président merci de me donner la parole
merci messieurs pour vos interventions
je crois que nous partageons tous à la
fois la prise de conscience sur ces
enjeux et les inquiétudes même si c'est
vrai que ce matin après tout ce que je
viens d'entendre j'avais un peu
l'impression que c'était les mercredis
du désespoir heureusement il y a eu
quand même quelques paroles plus
plein d'espoir et c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on regarde sur le terrain
lorsqu'on a quelques cheveux blancs et
qu'on voit les évolutions dans sa
commune sur le traitement de l'eau
depuis ses 25 dernières années il y a
tout de même eu un certain nombre de
progrès de réaliser d'investissement
d'engager de prise de conscience
également sur sur les rendements donc je
pense qu'il faut rappeler tout de même
les progrès que nous avons marqué dans
dans cette sur ce domaine
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été dites
moi je voudrais peut-être des précisions
sur la gouvernance et le financement
est-ce que finalement
cette idée d'avoir une gestion par
spécialisation thématique finalement où
on crée ou on renforce des structures
dédiées est-ce que finalement c'est pas
un peu contradictoire avec ce que vous
disiez au départ sur le fait que les
différentes gouvernances des
problématiques ne se parlent pas vous
parliez du sage qui ne parle pas au
stradettes etc est-ce que finalement si
on disait demain que le département qui
finalement a prouvé sur beaucoup de
sujets à la fois sa proximité sa
capacité d'intervention et ça et sa
légitimité si on disait que le
département porte la politique de l'eau
et
doit finalement
susciter ces débats ce dialogue et ces
programmes d'investissement est-ce que
finalement ce serait pas plus
intéressant puisque le département a
plein d'autres compétences y compris
social voire éc
si si on veut avoir une acceptation très
très large est-ce qu'il y a pas une
piste là quand même de réflexion ça
c'est le premier point sur le deuxième
point sur le financement
vous excuserez l'élu du Charolais que je
suis de d'en faire appel au bon sens
est-ce que au-delà de toutes les
gouvernants de toutes les réunions les
symposiums que l'on peut faire est-ce
que on pourrait pas par exemple
s'arrêter sur un élément d'évaluation ce
que vous pourriez nous dire par exemple
depuis 10 ans quel nombre de kilomètres
de réseaux d'eau ont été subventionnés
par les agences de bassin et avec ce
critère qu'elle amélioration du
rendement on a réalisé parce que lorsque
on parle avec les élus dans les
syndicats souvent on entend parler d'un
désengagement des agences de bassin de
choses qui étaient subventionnées il y a
10 ou 15 ans qui ne le sont plus
aujourd'hui donc est-ce que finalement
la première
c'est un peu ce que disait Rémi
Cointreau une bonne solution pour
économiser et être sobre est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas investir largement dans
l'amélioration des des réseaux et puis
enfin
il y a un autre question qui parcourent
beaucoup de
d'esprit ici au Sénat c'est la fameuse
débat sur la compétence ou
Assainissement
Communes intercommune est-ce que sur ce
point vous avez un
une opinion un somme de choses ont déjà
été dites mais un peu en même temps donc
qu'est-ce que vous pourriez clarifier
votre position sur le sujet merci
merci Madame filleul
si monsieur le Président merci aux
intervenants également pour la qualité
de leur interventions à ce stade
beaucoup de sujets ont déjà été évoqués
par mes collègues je vais donc poser
très brièvement les sujets que je
voulais évoquer à savoir comme Monsieur
Pointreau par exemple la question du
gaspillage de l'eau puisque 20% des 5,1
milliards de mètres cubes en
distribution sont perdus chaque année en
cours de route soit la consommation
annuelle de 18,5 millions d'habitants
moi aussi je voulais dire que la
priorité en matière de sobriété me
semble être la rénovation et l'entretien
des réseaux d'eau est-ce que ce sujet ne
doit pas être davantage mis en avant mis
en exergue dans toutes les
communications que nous faisons ensuite
je voulais évoquer la question des
événements extrêmes très brièvement vous
avez parlé des inondations des
sécheresses forcément mais on n'a pas
évoqué les communes qui sont confrontées
à l'augmentation du niveau de la mer et
qui tente
avec souvent l'aide des départements et
des régions de d'avoir des moyens de
résilience naturelle est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas là aussi une sorte de grand de
grands projets national à avoir pour
résoudre ces problèmes nos voisins du
Nord sont bien bien en avance sur nous
sur ces questions là
merci donc on se dit 12h15 12h20 maximum
je vais donner la parole représentant de
la mort c'est puis après vous d'accord
merci
globalement si je suis l'ensemble des
réactions on est tous en alerte sur le
sur le niveau des ressources et des
prospectives alors je vais essayer de
répondre à plusieurs techniques avant de
avant d'arriver à une
un avis un peu plus global monsieur
c'est Nathalie Go demande est-ce qu'il
existe des outils de prospective oui il
existe des prospectives les fameuses
études à schmück qui évalue les
ressources hydriques en fonction de
l'évolution du changement climatique
notre proposition là dessus c'est de les
généraliser justement au niveau des
sages on a parlé du sage et de la
généralisation du sage qui pourrait
eux-mêmes qui pourraient eux avoir une
vision prospective sur de la trajectoire
des ressources pour pouvoir se fixer des
partages des usages sur le périmètre de
chaque sage
il nous semble important aussi que les
autres outils de modifications
d'aménagement donc on a parlé de
stradettes on peut parler du Scott aussi
qui cet outil qui centralise justement
beaucoup d'outils de développement de
territoire
il faut que c'est l'ensemble de ces
outils très nombreux l'évolution des
ressources d'ici 20 à 50 ans on ne peut
plus voir se développer des zones
économiques ou des zones d'aménagement
ou des zones d'agriculture gourmandes en
eau sur des territoires qui sont déjà
critiques l'autre question sur sur le
suivi des consommations et notamment les
remontées
l'exemple des trois nouveaux captages
qui ont été établis et sur lequel le
même n'a pas du tout été sollicitée un
autre objectif dans dans le cadre de la
loi c'est justement de de faire de
manière plus fréquente l'évaluation des
des zones de répartition des ces zones
c'est ces zones qui définissent les
seuils d'autorisation et déclaration des
prélèvements donc là on rentre dans le
technique mais on sent bien que il y a
un problème de remontée des informations
des prélèvements dans les ressources et
du coup nous on assise sur le fait que
il faut des remontées de prélèvement
systématique que ça soit sur des forages
agricoles ou que ça soit aussi à étendre
au plus large justement la télé relève
qui permet de suivre les fuites après
compteur chez les individus parce que
vous avez beaucoup parlé des fuites du
réseau celle-ci on arrive à la mesure on
l'évalue on a des indicateurs qui le
suivent les fuites après après compteurs
sont toujours des domaines un peu
compliqués à évaluer
je voudrais revenir sur les questions
des pollutions diffuses oui nous sommes
complètement impliqués et concernés
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas nous un morceau de
partenariat avec lenses on en remettra
en compte sur la qualité d'analyse de
l'enss seulement ce qu'on observe c'est
que les seuils les molécules concernées
et les fameuses Vmax fluctue dans le
temps et on observe un deuxième
phénomène qui est que des produits qui
étaient déjà interdits depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années réémerge dans le sol
donc il y a il y a un cycle long donc ce
qu'on ce qu'on propose en termes
d'objectifs c'est bien sûr sur les airs
d'alimentation des captages de de
limiter largement les les intrants mais
par ailleurs
souvent on a tendance à dire qu'il faut
que du préventif en terme de politique
sur les micropoises sur les
micropollions
toutes les collectivités qui sont non
conformes comme vous l'avez vu sur l'eau
potable sont confrontés à des problèmes
de
donc il faut du financement aussi pour
financer des étapes de traitement
curatives puisque on est sur des
phénomènes long terme enfin nous la
proposition elle est de d'élargir les
devants le financement tout ce que vous
avez vu et tout ce qu'on a pu partager
en effet ne répond pas et ne peut plus
reposer à 80 % sur la facture de
l'usager domestique il faut réévaluer le
les redevances des agences de l'eau
c'est à dire que avoir intégré le Grand
Cycle c'est que l'eau et la biodiversité
payent l'eau et la biodiversité et
aujourd'hui on a un déséquilibre en
termes de recettes et de
et de redevance il y a un déséquilibre
dans les aides vous en avez parlé aussi
nous sommes importants que si on demande
des efforts de
limitation d'usage à chaque usager il
faut aussi
une révision du partage des financements
et de d'intégrer une nouvelle redevance
qui repose sur les micropollions les
micropolluants on en parle
on évoque et dans le colloque de
Bordeaux de l'Agence de l'eau à
bourg-garonne c'était très intéressant
on partage de nombreuses solutions
d'expériences de sensibilisation mais
aujourd'hui on n'a pas parlé financement
sur les micropollutions donc on incite
vraiment à créer une une responsabilité
énergie des producteurs à l'instar des
produits pour conclure s'il vous plaît
oui insta des produits sanitaires qu'on
a dans les agences de l'eau on pourrait
voir aussi une nouvelle redevance
micropollion qui qui permettrait
justement de financer notamment le parti
du grand cycle de l'eau en toute étape
nous sur l'ensemble des mesures qu'on
propose on propose pas le grand soir
mais bien des mesures pragmatiques avec
des objectifs chiffrés et je pense c'est
ce qui nous permettra d'avancer dans
l'enjeu de partage des ressources qui
est critiquent aujourd'hui merci je vais
donner
la parole à Monsieur Forel
oui mesdames messieurs on voit à travers
le nombre de questions que vous posez et
vous avez mesuré l'ampleur des sujets et
la quantité des sujets je crois quand on
est face à un défi comme celui-là avec
cette complexité la première chose qu'il
faut essayer de faire c'est de savoir
qui peut jouer quel rôle et à quel
endroit sur la question des normes
sanitaires
ça relève pleinement
d'un travail qui est propre à l'état
l'établissement de la règle dans
laquelle on doit maintenir la fourniture
de l'eau dire quel est le bon seuil et à
partir de quel moment il est possible de
la donner aux citoyens ou pas et ça doit
être quelque chose qui est la même sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
les établissements publics de bassins ne
peuvent pas faire ce genre de travail
c'est un travail normatif ça c'est un
travail qui appartient à l'État
et donc
comme vous que nous appelons qu'un
travail soit fait dans ce sens afin que
les choses soient éclairci la question
environnementale est devenue une
question d'opinion de plus en plus
prégnante
et y compris sur ces questions
normatives il ne passe quasiment pas un
jour sur les questions de pollution de
l'air ce question de pollution de l'eau
ou un nouveau
[Musique]
nouvelle norme apparaît je vous parle
pas des questions de
transfrontalière comme dans mon
territoire ou on a des échanges d'eau
avec la Suisse qui n'a pas le même type
de réglementation notamment il y a pas
longtemps sur une question liée au
perchlorate donc
il faut que chacun fasse ce qu'il a à
faire le dorbatif à mon sens c'est quand
même bien à l'état de le faire en
revanche et il y a une question qui a
été posée sur les ptge nous défendons
avec force et vous qui êtes le
représentant des élus territoire et de
la démocratie de proximité
que l'eau est une question qui se traite
au plus près du territoire et que les la
création d'établissements publics de
bassins qu'on les appelle les pages
qu'on leur donne tous les noms qu'on
veut n'est pas si important que ça
un établissement public de bassin qui
s'occupe du grand cycle et de sa
coordination avec le petit cycle qui
soit laissé aux mains des élus de
proximité ceux qui sont auprès du
territoire et qui à travers un document
renforcé dans sa capacité réglementaire
qui est le sage
décide à associer à une clé
décide de ce qui se passe sur le
territoire en conformité avec ce que
dans un comité de bassin plus grand on
est capable d'établir si on arrive à
donner cette existence là et cette force
là nous résoudrons beaucoup de problèmes
et les différences de pollution de
pratique de nécessité qui s'exprime dans
les territoires que ce soit sur les
questions des territoires littoral ou
des territoires de montagne comme le ou
les problèmes sont pas du tout les mêmes
ou ce qu'ils Massine peut se trouver ou
qu'une retenue colidaire peut se trouver
en montagne n'est pas du tout la même
chose que qui ce qui peut se passer en
pleine ou certains barrages peuvent être
installés lorsque c'est nécessaire le
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est qu'un
certain nombre de barrages ont du mal à
se remplir c'est là que le lien entre le
grand site et le petit cycle est
important à comprendre mais tous ces
particularités ne peuvent ne peuvent
être conçus abordés qu'à travers une une
présence locale forte je rappelle qu'une
commission locale de l'eau est aussi un
outil efficace pour régler les problèmes
de conflits
autour d'une commission locale de l'eau
pourra discuter de son équilibre de
représentation c'est toujours un vrai
débat mais tout de même tout le monde
est là
j'ai moi signé un sage ou le
représentant de FN2 a signé comme nous
comme les élus comme les mères et comme
les présidents comme ils ont signé on
l'a signé avec lui le même document on
l'a mis longtemps à le mettre au point
mais il est évident qu'en tout cas dans
mon territoire il était compliqué à la
FF2 devenir contester un dossier qui
avait été accepté dans une commission où
elle siégeait même avec une même une
vice-présidence donc on est en capacité
dans ces endroits là de résoudre et de
désamorcer un certain nombre de conflits
à côté de chez moi la Clusaz on n'est
pas aussi celle avec celle de solide
mais à La Clusaz il y a un problème qui
est en train de se passer de la même
manière
il se trouve que sur ce bassin vers son
là il y a pas cette établissement là
donc je je vous appelle à renforcer
réellement
cet établissement public de bassin qui
porte la démocratie locale et à
l'appuyer principalement sur le bloc
local sur la question de la compétence
eau et assainissement les les effets
d'échelle sont essentiels pour la
sécurité des approvisionnements et pour
la capacité un D de l'ingénierie très
vite beaucoup de territoire ont monté la
compétence à l'intercommunalité mais ce
qui est plus important surtout c'est que
d'être à des échelles qui sont des
échelles qui permettent de répondre aux
défis qui sont devant nous en termes de
quantité aussi bien d'ingénierie qu'en
diversification de la ressource et ça
fonctionne mais les le lien avec le
grand cycle est là aussi essentiel il y
a des questions qui étaient posées sur
l'aménagement oui monsieur sénateur nous
voyons dans les nouveaux élus des gens
qui proposent des approches
d'aménagement intéressantes
et oui les établissements publics de
bassins travaillent sur ces sujets
apportent des solutions
aident les collectivités à mettre en
place des schémas de cohérence de
traitement de l'eau pluviale
soutiennent des opérations qui
permettent de désimperméabiliser les
sols favorise les infiltrations d'eau le
fait d'avoir
nos collègues en collectivités
territoriales le fait de pouvoir
disposer d'une ingénierie d'un soutien
d'un partage dans leurs différents
actions d'aménagement du territoire à
travers l'établissement qui leur
rapporte l'expertise nécessaire la
perspective nécessaire pour pouvoir
mener leur leurs aménagements dans le
bon sens est un atout réel mais
pour que nos collègues dans les dans
l'immensité la diversité des tâches
qu'ils ont à remplir face des arbitrages
pour investir dans ces établissements
publics de bassin être présent être
actif s'investir dans des documents
comme le sage qui sont c'est vrai
compliqués parce que les problèmes sont
complexes mais qui sont qui peuvent être
rendus efficaces pour qu'il
s'investissent qu'ils donnent le temps
ils ne sont pas stupides ils
investissent du temps et de l'action
dans ce qui est efficient ils ne vont
pas perdre beaucoup un temps infini à
rédiger un document long et compliqué si
à la sortie ce document n'a pas une
efficacité forte sur ce qui se passe sur
le terrain c'est pourquoi il est
nécessaire que du point de vue
institutionnel ces établissements
publics de bassins et je réponds à votre
question monsieur c'est d'être gilet
pour moi oui il faut que l'établissement
public de bassin prennent un statut qui
lui donne de l'importance dans le
paysage institutionnel de manière à ce
que nos territoires et nos élus locaux
s'investissent sur ces sujets là pour
pouvoir
peser sur le sur la dimension politique
et à contrario pour être assez clair
monsieur sénateur vous vous appelez à
l'importance du département sur ces
sujets oui l'accompagnement du
département et des régions sont
fondamentales dans l'établissement
public de bassins mais je on le dit avec
force et on le répète vraiment beaucoup
mais c'est du d'importance claire ce
choix historique dans les années 60 de
travailler sur les grands bassins
versants étaient un choix fondamental et
tout à fait pertinent il est aujourd'hui
nécessaire de volu engence de reconduire
cette démarche à une échelle infra et il
faut absolument gérer la question de
l'eau à l'échelle du bassin versant or
les départements de recouvrent pas
nécessaire Sébastien Verseau cependant
il faut que les départements et les
régions soient associées à l'action des
des établissements publics de bassins
ils ont des compétences en matière
d'environnement ils peuvent donc
largement accompagner tout le travail
sur le gros cycle de l'eau et il faut le
redire fortement les tuyaux et vous avez
raison le l'étanchéité de nos transports
tout ça est essentiel mais le tuyau
pourront pas les remplir sur d'autres
grossi de l'eau est trop perturbée donc
il est nécessaire de travailler sur les
deux fronts et les départements les
régions sont les bienvenus au combien en
accompagnement de des établissements
publics de bassins cependant nous
pensons que la compétence bonne échelle
de compétences d'une compétence bassin
sur cette question du grand cycle et du
petit cycle doit bien rester appuyé sur
un bassin hydrographique et sur des
établissements publics de bassin
merci Monsieur Burlot
moi je voudrais dire d'abord un monsieur
Jeunet
que la Bretagne est la première région
d'Europe à être rentré dans les
contentieux sur les nitrates
parce qu'on est passé les fameux 50 mg
par litre dans les eaux superficielles
et aujourd'hui au moment où je vous
parle la région Bretagne et la première
région est sortie des contentieux
première région de Rome quand d'autres
régions d'Europe rentrent dans les
contentieux
je dis ça parce que quand on veut on
peut
et même en Bretagne avec l'agriculture
que vous connaissez tous de la Bretagne
on a réussi à relever le défi
donc quand on fait avec on a des
résultats
quand on fait compte c'est souvent la
bataille
donc il faut faire avec
et ça c'est très important
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
ça propose du rendement des réseaux il y
a un sujet
mais de toute façon plus les réseaux
sont longs notamment à la campagne
moins il y a de tirage
plus c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui on a des moyens de
diagnostiquer
techniques qu'on n'avait pas il y a 15
ans donc on sait aujourd'hui où les
réseaux sont fuyards et où il faut agir
en priorité donc il y aura un travail à
faire mais c'est du renouvellement de
canalisation c'est du renouvellement de
patrimoine commun qu'on n'a pas fait
parce qu'on a quasiment rien renouvelé
en France depuis la prière
donc ça le sujet alors on nous dit oui
les agences de l'eau vous payez pas mais
vous rendez compte le gouffre financier
que c'est
parce que là le plafond de mordant ne
suffira pas
donc est-ce qu'on intègre dans le prix
de l'eau le renouvellement du patrimoine
non évidemment
alors en plus j'ai une supercherie c'est
qu'à l'époque quand on signait ce qu'on
appelle des délégations de service
public le délégataire il avait dans son
contrat souvent le renouvellement des
canalisations ce qui n'a pas fait parce
que ça coûtait trop cher alors on sait
tous un peu
masqué le voile et la face mais
aujourd'hui on est devant une situation
qui va falloir prendre en considération
dans le prix de l'eau et et encore une
fois attention parce que dans le
rendement
il faut regarder ça très près parce
qu'il y a des endroits en effet où l'eau
était très abondante donc on s'occupait
pas du rendement puisque l'eau était
abondante
mais vous savez là où où il y a des
sujets de quantité depuis des années je
pense à la Vendée par exemple les choses
sont sérieusement prises en main croyez
bien donc je c'est un sujet mais mais
attention de ne pas cristalliser alors
sur le Grand Cycle le financement du
grand site pour répondre de différentes
questions et à la différence d'amorce
parce que je tiens le préciser à la
différence d'armes la question n'est pas
uniquement évidemment le sujet des
produits vétérinaires le sujet des
produits médicamentaux le sujet des
micro-articules de plastique vous savez
je sais pas si vous avez déjà vu ce
qu'on récupère dans un sèche-linge dans
le filtre
imaginez-vous ce qu'on récupère pas dans
la machine à laver qui part directement
aux égouts
les micro particules de plastique on est
tous concernés évidemment qu'on en
trouve dans l'eau puisque nos vêtements
tout ça c'est plein de plastique donc il
y a un sujet donc mais sur le grand
cycle de l'eau
je pense qu'il faut que on fasse le
bilan
de tous les dispositifs qu'on a
actuellement le premier c'est la gymapi
intéressant je vais inégalité
quand vous êtes dans un territoire
ruraux qui sont très larges mais je
pense vous savez le territoire où il y a
eu que Cynthia
ils ont 62 km de digue entre
vous imaginez 62 km de digue
ben oui ils arriveront pas enfin vous
voyez la taxe de Mappy qu'il faudrait
pour avoir parce que là on parle de
subversion avec tout ce qu'on connaît
derrière bon et et il y a des
territoires qui sont très peuplés
prudence et qui eux ont des taxes j'ai
ma pire ridicule quoi alors qu'ils
impactent en amont ou en aval enfin vous
voyez donc là il y a un bilan de la
gymapi à faire
je rappelle que le
montant total de la gymapi aujourd'hui
en France c'est l'équivalent à peu près
au plafond Morvan
280 millions d'euros c'est pas tout à
fait ça mais
pour donner un ordre ça c'est le premier
le deuxième sujet c'est le fond Marnier
qui progressivement est en train de
disparaître dans le budget général
fond Marnier attention c'est un fond qui
est utilisé et il faudrait en faire le
bilan
et je pense que là il y a parce que vous
avez dit quelque chose des épisodes
extrêmes on en aura de plus en plus
jusqu'où les assurances vont aller et
continuer à payer je vous parlais de
zynthia tout à l'heure vous savez que le
montant que j'aime tia la facture pour
l'État c'était 600 millions d'euros
l'État a acheté je sais plus combien de
maisons détruit des lotissements
626 maisons voilà
mais vous savez que la Roya l'épisode de
la Roya
un milliard un milliards
comment on va financer demain toutes ces
questions de donc j'ai Mappy fondier
pourquoi pas l'idée des reps sur des
produits toxiques etc je n'évacu pas ça
mais le grand cycle de l'eau c'est les
solutions fondées sur la nature c'est la
reconstitution des zones humides c'est
les paiements pour service
environnementaux c'est une multitude
d'actions qui va falloir mettre en
oeuvre et les budgets actuels des
agences de Londres ne suffiront pas
et j'ai envie de vous dire que si on
veut donner de la fierté à tout ça et du
sens commun il faut qu'on réfléchisse au
financement plus large du grand cycle de
l'eau intégrant tout ce que j'ai dit
et de poser uniquement la question des
reps ça serait mal regarder le sujet
alors là vous avez raison Madame loi
parce que il faut regarder ça on s'y
prend
parce qu'on va pas demander à chaque PTB
et à chaque agence de l'eau avec les
inégalités territoriales qu'on a déjà
constaté d'avoir une fiscalité propre il
faut quand même qu'on regarde un peu ça
de haut et donc dans cet état d'esprit
mon cher Frédéric on travaille sur les
propositions que le CNE pourrait faire à
la ministre en début d'année prochaine
donc on va essayer de travailler sur
d'ailleurs monsieur le Président si vous
voulez on reviendra vous voir parce que
le sujet est tellement vaste que le
sujet est tellement vaste que ça mérite
quand même attention mais moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'on regarde les choses un
peu globalement
sur la fiscalité et encore une fois
le sujet est important
la bataille de l'eau peut avoir lieu
peut avoir lieu je pense même que dans
certains endroits elle a lieu et moi je
suis sur le bassin de Loire Bretagne je
vous ai dit et en noir Bretagne on a une
centrale hydraulique qui s'appelle mon
pesa
qui est en Haute-Loire et qui produit de
l'eau qui est issue du bassin de la
Loire et qui la rejette dans le Rhône
via l'Ardèche
et ces 300 millions de mètres cubes
d'eau qui partent du bassin de la Loire
et qui vont alimenter l'Ardèche si on
les tire en Ardèche il y a plus d'eau
donc pour eux c'est vital mais les
collègues de la Loire qu'est-ce qu'ils
disent dans le Massif Central on nous
annonce et c'est pour ça que les
perspectives c'est intéressantes moins
30 % d'eau en 2050 dans la Loire
-30%. tout simplement parce que il neige
plus et donc on a plus de soutien des
tirages
vous rendez compte quand on dit ça au
Massif central ou Giscard des saints
dizaines notre président à l'époque
disait c'est le château d'eau de la
France
je vous assure qu'en Limagne les
agriculteurs et les coopératives
agricolesimages etc sont très très
inquiets parce que c'est leur modèle
économique qui est posé à travers tout
ça donc on a intérêt collectivement de
porter ses messages là et on a intérêt
droit la collectivité publique dans son
ensemble territoire et éteint d'être
ensemble sur ce sujet et on sera pas
trop croyez bien pour convaincre
qu'il faut qu'on trouve des consensus
des compromis parce que de toute façon
on pourra pas faire autrement
merci
allez-y on conclure juste en guise de
conclusion je vais pas revenir sur tout
ce qui a été dit mais deux petites
choses la première
on a on a envoyé il y a pas longtemps à
l'ensemble des parlementaires et donc
des mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
le livre bleu de l'année donc je ne sais
pas si vous l'avez reçu mais si elle
n'est pas le cas nous avons d'autres
exemplaires mais je vous invite quand
même à peut-être en prendre un peu
connaissance pour parce qu'il rentre
davantage dans les détails que nous ne
sommes capables de le faire en pareil
circonstances même si nous avons
beaucoup apprécié de pouvoir nous
exprimer devant vous et puis je lancerai
un appel à mon tour puisque Thierry
borlot l'a fait au titre du cercle
français de l'eau mais sachez que à
l'année aussi nous serions très heureux
d'accueillir d'autres parlementaires que
ceux avec lesquels nous avons le plaisir
de travailler et ce je le dis tout de
suite toute sensibilité politique
confondue
parce que vous l'aurez compris
si nous ne partageons pas ensemble
ensemble les choses et surtout si vous
n'êtes pas
nos relais sur un certain nombre en tout
cas de propositions
il y a un certain nombre de sujets qui à
nos yeux risquent de ne pas avancer au
rythme où nous pensons qu'il serait
utile qu'ils avancent donc
en tout cas soyez les bienvenus et nous
restons à votre entière disposition
autant qu'il le faudra
mais merci merci à vous quatre pour
effectivement répondu à notre invitation
alors on voit bien avec l'ensemble des
questions parce que c'est
des questions claires et précises et vos
réponses aussi et on voit bien tout le
travail qui est devant nous et la
sensibilisation qu'on a fait aussi parce
que je crois qu'on a effectivement à
sensibiliser nos concitoyens à
effectivement essayer d'être le plus
en parlant de l'Olympique possible
pour effectivement faire comprendre à
nos concitoyens que l'eau est un produit
aujourd'hui rare et qu'il faudra se
donner les moyens effectivement le
garder parce que vous savez moi dans mon
département j'ai une inquiétude
parce qu'il y a 4 ans
lorsqu'il y avait un étage très très
important
entre
maison du bois Lièvremont et Pontarlier
je suis allé sur place il y a 4 ans
puisqu'on m'a invité on m'a dit il faut
venir voir c'est c'est grave et depuis
l'été j'ai encore plus fort qu'avant
il est plus précoce qu'avant
mais on y va plus parce que je crois
qu'on a pris l'habitude
et ce qui est ce qui est très grave
parce qu'on s'est fait au phénomène ils
ont bah oui oh là là c'était grave il y
a 4 ans maintenant ça allait moins
maintenant c'est un phénomène normal et
je pense qu'il faut qu'on pense qu'il
faut qu'on réagisse sans alors c'est
compliqué parce que il faut réagir sans
être alarmiste mais en essayant d'être
convaincant alors merci pour pour vos
propos puis on aura l'occasion de se
revoir pour travailler ensemble merci à
vous